GREAT WELL GOOD AFTERNOON
WELCOME TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR- STATE. MAY THE FORCE BE
WITH US. FOR TODAY I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO BE CONTRACTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
TODAY HEARING TO HELP ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE OKAY
WELL ALLOWING PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THE S. AND- WE ARE IN ROOM FOUR
THREE SEVEN WE ARE HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DEFEND IN PERSON
HEARING WE ARE AND- AGAIN ROOM
FOR THREE SEVEN CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS THE
MINIMAL CONTINUE TO GO BACK.
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN JUST
SIX FEET OF FACING THEY'RE ALL
THE STRICT PHYSICAL BUSINESS
PROFILE FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER
IN THE CAPITAL I'M HERE TODAY
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WILL BE IT
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
AGAIN BUT IF ANY MEMBER. OF THE
PUBLIC KIND OF. THE ABLE RAISE
THEIR HAND AND I'LL HAVE TO
TALK. THE MICROPHONE. WHAT ARE.
OKAY. READ IT FOR OF THOSE DAYS.
WELL AGAIN AFTERNOON WELL TO
SUB FOR ON STATE ADMINISTRATION
HAVE TO TELL MY JOB AGAIN AND
MAY THE FOURTH BE WITH US TODAY
HERE WE GO TAKE TWO. I HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE A LITTLE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ASK ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. WE ARE IN ROOM FOUR
THREE SEVEN WE ARE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING AND CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBER
SEMINAL CONTENTION OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP SIX
FEET OF SPACING. THERE ARE ALSO
STRIPPED PHYSICAL DISTANCE
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WILL RESTATE
THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT BEGINS
BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK.
THEY WILL RAISE THEIR HANDS AND
I WILL ASK TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE I WOULD ASK THE
PUBLIC RESPECT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE
OBSERVE THE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITED ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON. AT A TIME. THE PANEL IS
ON THE AGENDA AN ALLEY- ARE
APPEARING MOSTLY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE ACCEPTING.
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN
YOU ARE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO BUDGET
STUFF FOUR. AD ASM DOT CA DOT.
G. O. V. SENSE WE HAVE QUORUM.
LET'S SAID TAKE THE ROLE PLEASE.
CARILLO HERE CHIU. COOPER YEAH
WACKY HERE THIS AREA. OKAY
MEMBERS TODAY'S THE FIRST DAY
WE WILL BE VOTING ON THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE LET'S START WITH
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR. CAN WE
TAKE A VOTE ONLY ON ISSUES. ONE
THROUGH TWENTY SECOND. OKAY A
ROLL CALL PLEASE WELL WE HAVE A.
YEAH LET'S DO THE WHOLE LIST
THIS ONE THROUGH. 202-223-3352
FORTY TO FORTY FOUR TO FIFTY
THREE. FIFTY FIVE TO FIFTY
EIGHT AND SIXTY JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION CAN I GET A
MOTION AND A SECOND PLACE.
SECOND GREAT- ROLL CALL PLEASE
CARILLO HI CHIU HI COOPER-
LACKEY HI THIS AREA. NEXT WE
WILL TAKE A VOTE ONLY ON ISSUES
AT TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR FIFTY
FOUR AND FIFTY NINE IS OUR
MOTION SOME OF. SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE CARILLO HI- HI
COOPER ARE LACKING. IN THIS
AREA. K. NEXT WILL TAKE UP THE
VOTE ONLY FOR ISSUE FORTY THREE
HAS OUR MOTION. SO IF. FOR A
SECOND. SECOND THANK YOU ROLL
CALL PLEASE CARILLO HI CHIU
NOBODY. COOPER HI LACKEY FIVE
THIS AREA. THE GREAT OF MOVING
ON TO THE ITEMS TO BE HEARD WE
WILL BEGIN WITH- EDT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FOR
ISSUE ONE JOINING US TODAY ARE
A DIRECTOR READ A SCIENCE
NINETY FARIAS KEVIN MODEL
WHICH- CAROL WILLIAMS ALL FROM
AT DHS ALUM WITH L. A. O. AND
MARK JIMENEZ WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LET'S
BEGIN. ARE WE HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES CAN WE- BEGIN THE
PANEL. LOOK UP CAN YOU HEAR ME
MADAM CHAIRPERSON. YES THANK
YOU MATH SCIENCE WILL SEE YOU
NOW. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I LOVE YOUR MASS. THANK
YOU A LITTLE LEVITY IN THESE
TYPES OF THINGS. SO EXPLORE
MORE FORMAL NOW THE DIRECT LINK
HERE WE ALL WE ALL NEED A
LITTLE A LITTLE LAUGH EVERY
ONCE IN AWHILE. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON ADAM CHAIRWOMAN. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY FOR THE RECORD I'M
LEADERS SCIENCE I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. THIS
DEPARTMENT HAS MANY CHALLENGES
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO EXPLAIN
HOW WE'RE HANDLING THEM. BEFORE
I DO THAT THOUGH I WANT TO
REMIND US OF THE CONTEXT OF OUR
SITUATION. WE TEND TO COMPARE
EDT PANDEMIC ISSUES TO THE
GREAT RECESSION. WITHIN MY FOUR
MONTHS AT THE DEPARTMENT. I SEE
THAT THAT'S NOT A GOOD
COMPARISON. THE GREAT RECESSION
CAME UPON US RELATIVELY
GRADUALLY THE PANDEMIC STRUCK
SUDDENLY. WE WENT FROM THREE
POINT 9% UNEMPLOYMENT 217%
UNEMPLOYMENT ALMOST OVERNIGHT.
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE GREAT
RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
D. D. D. EIGHT THREE MILLION
CLAIMS A YEAR. AT THE OUTSET OF
THE PANDEMIC WE PAID OVER THREE
MILLION CLAIMS IN EIGHT WEEKS.
SINCE THE END OF DECEMBER WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED TO MASSIVE
FEDERAL STIMULUS PACKAGES WITH
CHANGES IN BENEFITS
REQUIREMENTS AND EXTENSIONS. D.
D. D. IS NOW PAYING ONE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS IN CLAIMS
A WEEK. SO LET'S GET TO BE THE
PRIMARY FOCUS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT NOW. GETTING CLAIMS
PAID MANAGING THE CALL CENTER
AND IMPROVING THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE COULD BE FRAUD.
AFTER THE PANEL WILL BE GLAD TO
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
REMEMBERS HALF. SINCE PRESIDENT
BIDEN SIGNED THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ON MARCH ELEVENTH
WE HAVE ENSURED. THAT MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO GET
PAID FEDERAL BENEFITS. EVERY
CALIFORNIA COLLECTING ON AN
EXISTING FEDERAL. AND IT
ENDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
CLAIM WAS ABLE TO CERTIFY AND
RECEIVE BENEFITS SINCE MARCH.
MUCH FASTER THAN OUR ORIGINAL
APRIL TENTH DEADLINE. THOSE ARE
REGULAR STATE UNEMPLOYMENT
OFFENDED RECEIVE THE EXTRA
THREE HUNDRED FEDERAL PAYMENTS
WITHOUT INTERRUPTION. IT UC
CLAIMANTS HAVE ALSO BEEN MOVED
TO THEIR NEW EXTENSIONS.
CALIFORNIA IS PROCESSING NEARLY
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND CLAIMS
EACH WEEK THAT IS MORE THAN THE
SECOND AND THIRD LARGEST STATES
FLORIDA TEXAS BUYING. DESPITE
THAT MASSIVE WORKLOAD. WE HAVE
MADE PROGRESS IN SEVERAL AREAS
BY THE END OF JANUARY WE
LIQUIDATED THE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION CLAIMS BACKLOG
IDENTIFIED BY THE STRIKE TEAM
IN SEPTEMBER. WE'VE MADE
IMPROVEMENTS LIKE TEXT
MESSAGING NOTIFICATION AND
DOCUMENTS UPLOAD FOR BETTER
COMMUNICATION AND IMPROVED
SERVICES. TO OUR CLIENTS. WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STRIKE
TEAM. AND THE STATE ARCHER. WE
LAUNCHED A NEW DASHBOARD ON OUR
WEBSITE SO THAT WHAT WE ARE
DOING CAN BE TRANSPARENT. THE
BACKLOG OF CLAIMS PENDING THE
DEPARTMENT'S AFTER ACTION.
LONGER THAN THREE WEEKS IS
CURRENTLY ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY. WHILE THIS
HAS FALLEN 40% SINCE FEBRUARY
HE'S CLEARLY NOT ENOUGH AND I'M
SURE YOUR STAFF HAVE TOLD YOU
THAT. EACH OF THE FEDERAL
EXTENSIONS NECESSITY
NECESSITATES A NEW EDUCATION
PROGRAM. TO HELP CLAIMANTS AND
CLAIM PROCESSORS I UNDERSTAND
THE NEW REQUIREMENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE. IF YOU HAVE A REGULAR
STATE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CLAIM YOU MUST FILE A NEW CLAIM
WITH THE BENEFIT YEAR ENDS IN
ORDER TO COLLECT ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS. BUT IF YOU'RE ON THE
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
FILE A CLAIM. I WILL TELL YOU
THAT COMMUNICATING THESE KEY
DIFFERENCES TO MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE IS A CHALLENGE. MYERS
DEVELOPING MATERIALS TO HELP
PEOPLE DETERMINE WHAT TYPE OF
CLAIM THEIR OWN AND WHAT IF
ANYTHING THEY NEED TO DO NEXT.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE COMPLICATED.
AND WE KNOW THAT'S VERY
FRUSTRATING TO OUR CLIENTS. SO
WE CONDUCT PUB PUBLIC OUT
WHICH- AS A RESULT OF THAT
OUTREACH THERE WERE OVER THREE
AND A HALF MILLION VISITS TO
OUR WEB PAGE TO CLARIFY THE END
OF THE BENEFIT YOUR PROCESS. WE
HAVE DEVELOPED MORE VIDEOS TO
HELP OUR ASK ANY YOUTUBE VIDEO
ON THE BENEFIT YEAR AND AS HAD
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
VIEWS IN THE THREE WEEKS SINCE
IT WAS POSTED. WE'RE ALSO
CONDUCTING OUTREACH TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE. THAT HELPS CLAIMANTS
ACCURATELY ANSWER THEIR
CONTINUED CLAIM FORM QUESTIONS
BOTH ENGLISH AND SPANISH. ALL
THESE CHANGES HAVE RESULTED IN
A SEARCH YOU ARE ALL AWARE OF
THAT. SO RECENTLY WE RE
DIRECTED ADDITIONALLY YOU WHY
STAFF TO WORK ON LEGISLATIVE
REFERRALS AND WE HAVE JUST READ
REDIRECTED. ADDITIONAL TRAINED
STAFF FROM OTHER BRANCHES OF
THE DEPARTMENT TO BACK FILL
BEHIND THEM AND ASSIST WITH
CLAIMS. THESE IMPROVEMENTS ARE
SIGNIFICANT. BUT THEIR LITTLE
COMFORT TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING THEIR BENEFITS. FOR US
LIKE YOU EVERY CLIENT MATTERS.
WE CONTINUE TO PUT INTENSIVE
pWHAT WE'RE DOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT ELIGIBLE QUICK LET'S GET
PAID. AND WE'RE DOING THIS IN
THE FACE OF THE COMPLICATIONS
CAUSED BY IMPLEMENTING THESE
WELCOME NEW FEDERAL PROGRAMS.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT AREAS
OF MY FOCUS HAS BEEN ON EACH
CALL CENTER OPERATIONS. THE
CHALLENGE WITH THE CALL CENTER
IS RELATED TO THE SPEED OF
PAYMENT IT'S OBVIOUS BUT WORTH
MAKING EXPLICIT THE FASTER WE
PAY BENEFITS THE FEWER CALLS
CLAIMANTS NEED TO MAKE. MOST
CALLERS ARE CALLING ABOUT
EXISTING CLAIMS. AS CLAIMS GET
RESOLVED THE CALL STOCK. THAT'S
WHY IN JANUARY WE STARTED TO
BRING ON HUNDREDS MORE
PERMANENT STATE STAFF WHO CAN
PROCESS CLAIMS AND GET ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE PAID. BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM STATES AROUND
THE COUNTRY ARE UNANIMOUS IN
SAYING THAT IT TAKES SIX TO
EIGHT MONTHS TO FULLY TRAINED
AN AGENT. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
REDUCE THAT TO FOUR MONTHS
THAT'S AS ABOUT THE VISION AS
WE CAN MAKE IT WITH ENSURING
HIGH QUALITY SKILLS. SELF HELP
AND BETTER PUBLIC INFORMATION
IS HELPING TO REDUCE SOME CALL
CENTER PRESSURE. WE MONITOR A
VARIETY OF SOURCES FOR COMMON
QUESTIONS AND AREAS ARE PUBLIC
CONFUSION. AND WE ADDRESS THAT
WITH BETTER PUBLIC INFORMATION.
OVER THE LAST FIVE WEEKS THE
CALL CENTER WE SEE OVER WHAT
SEVENTEEN MILLION CALL ACCOUNTS
OF NEARLY 50% DROP FROM THE
SAME PERIOD LAST YEAR. STILL
THE AVERAGE IS NEARLY SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALL ATTEMPTS
PER GAME AND IS MORE THAN THE
CALL CENTER CAN HANDLE EVEN
THOUGH IT IS RUNNING TWELVE
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
THOSE SEVENTEEN MILLION CALLS
WERE MADE BY ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION INDIVIDUAL CALLERS.
CALL CENTER I'M GONNA SAY THAT
AGAIN THE CALLS WERE MADE BY
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
INDIVIDUAL CALLERS IN OUR CALL
CENTER STAFF ANSWERED ONE POINT
THREE MILLION OF THOSE CALLS.
WE HAVE ADDED MORE ONLINE SELF
SERVICE OPTIONS TO HELP PEOPLE
AVOID MAKING ANY CALL AT ALL.
WE'VE ALSO IDENTIFIED TOP
CLAIMING QUESTIONS AND PROVIDE
RESPONSE RESPONSIVE INFORMATION
WEEKLY ON EDIE'S WEBSITE IN OUR
GENERAL MEDIA SOCIAL MEDIA AND
EXPANDED STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH.
EARLIER THIS YEAR I ADVICE THE
COMMITTEE THAT MANY OF THE
USEFUL FEATURES OF THE CALL
CENTER HAD BECOME UNUSABLE GOOD
USABLE WHEN WE DISPERSED AFTER
THEIR HOMES WE ARE NOW
REINSTATED SOME OF THOSE
FEATURES. TWO WEEKS AGO WE
LAUNCHED. WE LARGER VIRTUAL
HOLD FEATURE ON A LIMITED BASIS
THAT ALLOWS CALLERS TO HOLD
THEIR PLACE IN LINE AND HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT CALLED THEM BACK.
THE EXPANSION OF THIS FEATURE
WILL CONTINUE THROUGH EARLY
JAIL. IN THIS LIMITED TIME
WE'VE HAD- WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REACH FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN PEOPLE ARE THERE SEEMED
TO BE HAVING SOME SUCCESS WITH
US SO. WE ARE GOING TO DO WHAT
WE CAN TO ACCELERATE. WE'RE
INVESTING MILLION DOLLARS IN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER SERVICES
FOR OUR CALL CENTER TO SERVE
CLAIMANTS IN POTENTIALLY
HUNDREDS OF LANGUAGES. WE HAVE
DEDICATED PHONE LINES IN
ENGLISH SPANISH CANTONESE
MANDARIN AND VIETNAMESE. ONE OF
OUR TOP GOALS IS TO CREATE A
MULTILINGUAL TRANSLATION AND
INTERPRETER SERVICE TO HELP
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
CLAIMANTS ACCESS THEIR PROGRAMS
THIS WILL INCLUDE A
MULTILINGUAL ACCESS PROGRAM AND
OTHER NEW LDP SERVICES. WE HAVE
TO REACH MORE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND MAKE AN INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH SPECIALIZED
LOCAL AND IN LANGUAGE MEDIA.
FINALLY WE RECOGNIZE THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS DO NOT HAVE EITHER
THE ACCESS OR THE ABILITY TO
USE THE INTERNET AND WE
CONTINUE TO TALK TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVE THESE
PEOPLE REGULARLY FOR BETTER
WAYS TO REACH. TALK ABOUT
PRODUCT PER SECOND. LAST YEAR
WE TOOK OUR STEPS TO ENHANCE
OUR FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE UNPRECEDENTED IMPOSTOR
FRAUD SEEN HERE AND NATIONWIDE.
THE CRIMINAL SCHEMES MOVED TO
OTHER STATES WITH WEAK WEAKER
FRAUD FILTERS WHEN WE INITIATED
OUR FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION. SYSTEMS WHAT WE ARE
STILL RECEIVING FRAUDULENT
FORMS THREE HUNDRED UNIFICATION
OF VERIFICATION AND ROBUST
FRAUD FILTERS TO CHECK CLIMATE
INFORMATION AGAINST DATABASES
FROM THOMSON REUTERS TO PROTECT
AGAINST THIS CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR.
THERE ARE NO EFFORTS COULD
TRIED SUCH A STRONGER
IDENTIFICATION WITH ID ME THAT
THEY'VE ADDED ANOTHER LAYER OF
REVIEW. THIS NO MEASURE HAS
STOPPED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
POTENTIAL FRAUD. HOWEVER WE
HAVE NOT YET STRUCK THE BALANCE
WE NEED BETWEEN SECURITY AND
SPEED. WE ARE NOTIFYING IN OUR
FRAUD FILTERS SO THAT ALLEGED
TO MAKE CLAIMANTS ARE NOT NOT
NECESSARILY CAUGHT UP OR
DELAYED BECAUSE OF OUR FRAUD
PREVENTION EFFORTS. JUST TO
MAKE IT THAT UP 235% OF CLAIMS
LAST YEAR OR FRAUDULENT. ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. WE INTEND TO MAKE
EVERY EFFORT TO HOLD THOSE
CRIMINALS ACCOUNTABLE. OUR
INVESTIGATION UNIT CONTINUES TO
PROVIDE VALUABLE LEADS AND
EVIDENCE TO LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS AND
PROSECUTORS. WE ARE SEEING A
RISE IN THE TIDE OF SEARCH
WARRANTS ARRESTS PROSECUTIONS
AND CONVICTIONS. JUST LAST WEEK
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES ANNOUNCED THAT STATE
TASK FORCE ON PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE FRAUD.
HAS LED TO THE ARREST OF SIXTY
EIGHT SUSPECTS AND OPENED ONE
THOUSAND AND SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
ADDITIONAL INVESTIGATIONS AND
THIS WILL CONTINUE TO RAMP UP.
THE BILL STRONG PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SHARE
DATA WITH OTHER JURISDICTIONS
TO HELP CATCH MULTISTATE
PROCTOR'S. WE ARE PROSPERITY
DAY GET AGAINST LAW ENFORCEMENT
RECORDS SUSPECTING MULTIPLE
CLAIMS FROM A SINGLE ADDRESS
FOR FURTHER INVESTIGATION AND
WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED THE STATE.
ALL PROP OFF FRONT AND
PREVENTION EFFORTS IN EDT. WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO HELPING
VICTIMS WITH OUR OF THE
IDENTITY FRAUD WE KNOW
CRIMINALS USED ARE REAL BUT
STILL STOLEN IDENTITIES FROM
THE DARK WEB FILE FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS. IN RESPONSE WE'RE
CONTINUALLY REACHING OUT TO THE
PUBLIC ON HOW TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AGAINST IDENTITY
THEFT. WE ALSO HELP PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVED A TEN NINETY NINE G.
SHOWING UNEMPLOYMENT
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THAT THEY
DID NOT RECEIVE. HOWEVER AS
I'VE SAID ARE FRAUD FILTERS
KEVIN WOODLEY SWEPT UP
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS SO WE
STILL HAVE YES WE WERE STILL IN
A PLACE WHERE WE HAVE TO
REASSESS THOSE FILTERS. IN
CLOSING ARE. THE FOCUS OF THE
D. D. SINCE THE PANDEMIC HAS
ALWAYS BEEN TO TRY TO DO WHAT
IS BEST FOR CLAIMANTS.
SOMETIMES WE DO IT WELL.
SOMETIMES WE'RE NOT AS
SUCCESSFUL. DURING THE WORST
YEAR OF THE GREAT RECESSION AS
I SAID THERE ARE THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION CLAIMS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THERE
HAVE BEEN TWENTY TWO MILLION
CLAIMS FILED IN THIS PANDEMIC.
A VALUE OF WORK HAS BEEN
STAGGERING. DURING THE SAME
TIME THIS WAS HAPPENING. WE
WERE MOVING THE ENTIRE WORK
FORCE TO REMOTE TO REDUCE THE
SPREAD OF THE CORONAVIRUS MASS
HIRING REDIRECTING WORKERS FROM
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT BORROWING
WORKERS FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS
CONTINUING TO STAFF UP IN THE
USE OF ANDERS HAVE ALL BEEN A
PART OF AN EFFORT TO RESPOND TO
THE HISTORIC DEMAND FOR
BENEFITS DURING AN
UNPRECEDENTED NATIONAL
EMERGENCY. DESPITE THOSE
DISRUPTIONS WE MANAGED TO PAY
OVER A HUNDRED AND FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN BENEFITS. WE
HAVE HANDLED MAJOR PROBLEMS
ELIMINATED THE ONE POINT SIX
MILLION BACKLOG OF CLAIMS OPEN
IN THE CALL CENTER TO RUN
TWELVE HOURS A DAY. SEVEN DAYS
A WEEK HIRING HUNDREDS. OF NEW
STATE WORKERS AND LAUNCHING NEW
IDENTIFICATION VERIFICATION. TO
PREVENT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
STATE PRIDE. ALSO WE ARE NOW IN
THE PROCESS. REDESIGNING A NEW
BENEFIT SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE BEST
INFORMATION FROM WHAT WE DID
BEFORE WITH THE BENEFIT SYSTEMS
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS THE
LESSONS THAT WE AND OTHER
STATES LEARNED DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND NEW SOFTWARE THAT
HAS BECOME AVAILABLE SINCE WE
STARTED THE PROJECT. THERE ARE
NEW CHALLENGES. PROCESSING THE
CLAIMS AS MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
REACHED THE END OF YOUR
RECEIVING BENEFITS INTEGRATING
VERIFICATION PROCEDURES
REDUCING THE BACKLOG OF A
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
CLAIMS AND WORKERS PROSECUTORS
TO HOLD SOPHISTICATED
FRAUDSTERS LAST YEAR
ACCOUNTABLE. WE HAVE A SOLID
ROADMAP FROM STRIKE JAMES AND
THE AUDITOR AND WE ARE PUTTING
THOSE CHANGES IN PLACE. I WANT
TO THANK LEGISLATORS WHO HAVE
IN SO MANY WAYS CONSISTENT
CONSISTENTLY OFFERED ME AND THE
DEPARTMENT HELP AND ADVICE. AND
TO THEIR STAFF. WHO HAVE SERVED
OUR CLAIMANTS WHO ARE THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. MORE HELP IS
COMING. FILING MANY THANKS TO
OUR MAGNIFICENT STAFF HAVE
STEPPED UP FROM OTHER PARTS OF
EDT THE RESPONSE. TO THE
EMERGENCY I AM HOPING THAT
TODAY WE ENGAGE IN A PRODUCTIVE
DIALOGUE THAT WILL HELP TO
ACCELERATE OUR PROCESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DIRECTOR SCIENCE
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM THE L. A.
O. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BEFORE WE OPEN IT UP TO
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MR ALUM. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAD ALAMO WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WORK HERE- AS ALWAYS TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE THAT HAVE ON THIS
INFORMATIONAL ITEM- BEYOND
DIRECTOR SENTENCES OUT. RESET
UPDATE AND NOT HAPPY TO GET
BACK AS WELL TO THE- STAFF OF
THE COMMITTEE WITH ANY LONGER
TERM REQUESTS- THAT REQUIRE A
LITTLE MORE DATA WORKER
COMMUNICATIONS DEPARTMENT. AS
ALWAYS HERE TO ASSIST THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MESS AROUND IS FOR HIM. HI
BETTER TOP DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REPORTER MIKE MINUTES
CAN'T BE HERE TODAY AND I'M
THINKING I'M IN LABOUR
ASSIGNMENT AT THIS TIME-
FINANCE HAS NOTHING TO ADD BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU GUYS HAVE. AS A
MAINTENANCE ITEM. THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU THEN LET'S GO
TO OUR COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
BUT LET ME TAKE A MOMENT
PRIVILEGE AND JUST ASK- IT
DIRECTOR SIGNS. YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOU WERE TAKING B. YOU
WERE GOING TO CREATE A FRAUD
UNIT WHEN WILL THAT BE. A
ENACTED. ACTUALLY WE ALREADY
HAVE CREATED IT. WHEN WAS IT
CREATED IT'S CREATED IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS. OKAY AND
HOW MANY HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN
THAT PARTICULAR DEPARTMENT. IT
IS A COMBINATION OF THE IT'S IT
WE'RE DOING IT LIKE A NETWORK
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
EVERYONE OF THE BRANCHES AND
THEY'RE MEETING REGULARLY. WE
HAVE NOT CREATED A SEPARATE
UNIT AS OF YET. WE ARE WORKING
ARE TO COLLABORATE ACROSS ALL
OF THE BRANCHES. OKAY I GUESS
WE'D JUST LIKE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING IN TERMS OF WHAT
DOES THIS THE POTENTIAL UNIT
LOOK LIKE HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
BEHIND IT AND WHAT IS IT. HOW
ARE YOU MEASURING YOUR LEVELS
OF FRAUD IN TERMS OF FOLKS THAT
ARE ALSO RECEIVING FRAUD
NOTIFICATIONS AT HOME OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO RECEIVE THEIR
BENEFITS IN COLLABORATION WITH.
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT YOU NOW
HAVE LOOKING AT WHAT IS
DETERMINED OF THE FRAUD. WE CAN
PROVIDE YOU WITH MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT. OKAY
GREAT- ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS-
HAS THERE BEEN OR WHY HAZARD
WHY HAS A PROGRESS RECENTLY
SLOW DOWN ON THE TWENTY ONE DAY
BACKLOG ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
FALLING CASELOAD NUMBERS.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION. PART
OF IT IS DUE TO THE SURGE
HAVING TO DO WITH THE NEW
PROGRAMS THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN. OKAY WHEN DO YOU SO THAT
SO. REMEMBER OUR AND IF YOU
JUST HAPPEN IT DOES CDSS WHEN I
READ IT WELL WE HAD CASELOADS
WHAT HAPPENS IS A LARGE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE COME OFF IN A LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE COME ON. SO A
LOT OF THIS LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE COMING ON ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ASKING QUESTIONS. ABOUT
THESE NEW FEDERAL EXTENSIONS.
SO ARE YOU YOU SEEN IT IN YOUR
OFFICE AS WELL I'M SURE. PEOPLE
WITH NO PEOPLE WITH QUESTIONS.
MORE THERE'S THERE SEEMS TO BE
FROM JUST CONVERSATIONS WITH OF
FELLOW LEGISLATORS THAT THEY'RE
JUST EVEN WITH THE IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE CALL CENTER IT'S STILL
VERY DIFFICULT FOR.
CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE TO
REACH SOMEONE OVER THE PHONE OR
HAVE THEIR EMAILS BE RETURNED
IN A TIMELY MANNER OR HAVE ANY
TYPE OF CORRESPONDENCE THAT'S
TIMELY SO I'M JUST CURIOUS- IN
TERMS OF THE BACKLOG. OUT WHY
THERE'S A SLOW DOWN WHEN
THERE'S ALSO AN INCREASE OF
STAFF AND LESS CASE CASE
NUMBERS AND AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION IS WAS THERE. THIS
THIS PROBLEM EXIST PRIOR THAT
EDIE DEAN ALSO HAVE THIS SAME
SITUATION BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
THERE IS A PERCENTAGE OF
BACKLOG- A STANDARD. THAT IS
ESTABLISHED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR. I THINK THE BACKLOG
OF LABOR IS 10% THAT IS
CONSIDERED TO BE BEYOND THAT IS
NOT ACCEPTABLE. IN THE PAST.
EDG HAD A PERCENTAGE OF 8%
GENERALLY. SO BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC YOU KNOW WE DIDN'T
HAVE THIS TYPE OF A SITUATION
WHERE SO MANY PEOPLE WERE
SUDDENLY UNEMPLOYED AND ARE NOT
WEEK COMING BACK AGAIN FOR
BENEFITS BUT I'D BE GLAD TO
HAVE EITHER ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES- GIVE BETTER DETAIL
ON THAT. CHAVEZ CAROL WILLIAMS
I CAN ATTEMPT TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION YOU CONCERNED- BUT
YOU'RE AWARE JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- WE REINSTATED DOING
DETERMINATION INTERVIEWS OF THE
CLAIM IT HAS AN ELIGIBILITY
ISSUE. SO THIS AGAIN DOING
THOSE DETERMINATION INTERVIEWS
PREDATES- THE PANDEMIC WE
WEREN'T DOING THEM DURING THE
PANDEMIC NOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN
REINSTITUTED. IT IS SLOWER
BECAUSE WE ARE FINDING THAT WE
NEED TO RETRIEVE MORE
INFORMATION FROM CLIENTS FOR
EXAMPLE CLIMATE STATE THAT THEY
WERE FIRED OR THEY QUIT- IT
REQUIRES EDT TO MANUALLY REVIEW
THE CLAIM BEFORE DETERMINING IF
THAT CLAIM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS AND THAT IS TAKING
QUITE A BIT TIME- FOR THAT
RESONATOR DOES THAT MAKE THEM.
GEN VENTURA WELL I THINK WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET AT IS YOU
KNOW IF YOU LOOK IF YOU GO TO
THE IF YOU LOOK AT. THE BACKLOG
AT LEAST FOR THE TWENTY ONE
DAYS ON YOUR WEBSITE AND THEN
YOU THINK ABOUT AND YOU
CORRELATE THAT WITH THE FALLING
CASELOAD NUMBERS. AND INCREASES
TO THE CALL CENTER AND
ADDITIONAL HELP I'M JUST
CURIOUS AS TO WHY. IT DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE IMPROVING. IT IS S.
B. IT IS DEFINITELY A SPEED
ISSUE WHEN WE HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH THE ACCOUNTS
INDIVIDUALLY WE CANNOT DO IT-
APPLYING MANUAL- FOR AN
AUTOMATED SOLUTION TO THEM.
IT'S THE IT IT IS THE TIME AND
THAT TIME OF A LAPSING IS WHAT
YOU'RE EXPERIENCING IS WHAT THE
CLAIMS ARE EXPERIENCING IT'S
WHY THINGS ARE FEELING LIKE.
WHAT THINGS ARE IMPROVING
THINGS ARE ALSO SLOWER MOTION
REMEMBER THE ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION IN THE INTERVIEWS
WERE NOT HAPPENING- PRIOR TO
THIS CALENDAR YEAR. HOPE THAT
HELPS UNDERSTAND IT THE VARIOUS
WITH EDT IF I COULD JUST ADD
ONE THING- YOU KNOW THAT THE
DIRECTOR MENTIONED IN HER-
OPENING ABOUT THE BENEFIT YEAR
ENDING THAT'S ALSO CAUSING AS
AS THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED- SOME
CONFUSION AND SOME- ADDITIONAL
CALLS INTO THE CALL CENTERED
BECAUSE- IF IT'S- IT IS
CONFUSING AS SHE MENTIONED
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WOULD HAVE
TO REAPPLY OR NOT- AND THAT IS
AN ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD. THANK
YOU I HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
BUT I ALSO WANT TO OPEN IT UP
TO OUR MY COLLEAGUES HERE AND
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO OUR BUDGET
CHAIRMAN SITTING. I JUST GOT A
COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS. WERE
WERE NOTICING A SURGE IN CALLS
FROM THE- FOLKS WHO ARE DOING
THEIR ANNUAL RENEWAL FONG AND
WE'VE BEEN GETTING- A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF-
COMPLAINTS AGAIN AS OUR AS OUR
CHAIR. A LITTLE TOO ABOUT NOT
BE ABLE TO GET A HOLD OF
ANYBODY OR NOT BILL TO RESOLVE
ISSUES BECAUSE THEY'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTY RENEWING- THERE ARE
CLAIMS HAVE YOU ALSO BEEN I
ASSUME YOU'VE ALSO BEEN SEEING
THIS AND JUST CURIOUS. ON HOW
YOU'VE BEEN HANDLING THE
PROBLEM YES SIR- WE MOST
CERTAINLY HAVE AND IT'S THE
REASON THAT WE'RE GOING TO.
WHERE WE'RE EXPLORING AND-
PURSUING THIS VIRTUAL A VIRTUAL
HOLD CALL SYSTEM WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS A COMBINATION OF
PEOPLE THAT SOMETIMES DOESN'T
OCCUR TO PEOPLE THAT WHILE
YOU'RE WAITING IF YOU HANG UP
YOU LOSE YOUR- HERE'S WHERE YOU
ARE YOU'RE NOT WHERE YOU ARE IN
LINE WHERE YOU ARE IN THE
QUEUE. SO WHAT HAPPENS IS
PEOPLE HANG UP WHEN THEY CALL
AGAIN. AND I'M SURE YOU'RE STEP
HAS HEARD JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE
HEARD THIS PEOPLE WILL CALL
TWENTY TIMES THIRTY TIMES
DURING THE DAY EACH TIME
GETTING IN A NEW PLACE IN THE
QUEUE. ARE WE ARE ALSO
DISCOVERING THAT THERE IS SOME
SORT OF AN AUTOMATED COLLEEN
IT'S HAPPENING NOW. SOME SORT
OF A NATIONAL SYSTEM WHERE YOU
CAN PAY SOMEBODY I THINK TWENTY
DOLLARS AND- THEY'LL KEEP
CALLING UNTIL THEY GET SOMEBODY.
SO YOU HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF CALLING BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO GET IN YOUR HEART AND
YOUR STAFF IS HURTING. WE'RE
HOPING THAT BY GOING TO THIS
VIRTUAL HOLD WHAT WILL HAPPEN
IS PEOPLE WILL KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE A PLACE IN LINE. AND THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THEM BACK
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO MAKE
THESE TEN OR FIFTEEN OR TWENTY
CALLS EVERY DAY. WE'VE ALSO
STRENGTHENED WHAT WE HAVE ON
THE WEBSITE NOW ONE OF THE
THINGS I'M GOING TO ASK THE
MEMBERS- YOU KNOW ACT I KNOW
THAT AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
WEBSITE PEOPLE REPORTED TO ME
THAT THE WEBSITE WAS NOT. AS
USEFUL AS IT COULD BE IT IS
MUCH BETTER NOW AND WE ARE
REALLY ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO DO
SELF SERVICE. IS THAT WHAT YOU
KNOW THAT WILL REDUCE THE
CALLS. WILL REDUCE PEOPLE
HAVING TO SIT ON THE AYE AYE I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT- AFTER
HAPPEN ARE WAITING ON THE LINE.
HERE STARTS TO FALL OUT. SO I
CAN COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE TO WAIT FOR HOURS. SO
THIS IS A SYSTEM WILL HAVE BEEN
BY JUNE. OKAY OKAY THAT.
ADOPTING OUR CHALLENGES AS WE
START TO OPEN UP. OUR DISTRICT
STAFF WHO OF MANY OF US ARE
MOST OF US HAVE ALMOST
PRIMARILY BEEN- FIELDING EDT
CALLS WAS TRYING TO GET THIS
INFLUX OF CALLS BUT WE ALSO WE
ALSO NEED TO START DIRECTING
OUR STAFF TO. OTHER KINDS OF
WORK SO WE- WE CAN'T DO THAT
BUT WE'RE IN THE SITUATION WITH
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE NOT
ADDRESS BECAUSE THIS CAN GET A
HOLD OF YOU. I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND AND IT'S THE REASON
THAT I HAVE ADDED ANOTHER
HUNDRED AND TWENTY PEOPLE. TO
WORK THE LEGISLATIVE CASTLE.
AND THAT JUST THIS LAST WEEK
ACT RIGHT HERE YOU I YOU KNOW I
REALLY APPRECIATE PEOPLE CALL
ME A LEGISLATORS CALL ME. TEXT
ME THEY LET ME KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING IT WAS CLEAR THAT THE
SURGE HAD REACHED OUT THE DOOR
LEGISLATIVE OFFICERS I'VE HEARD
DARK DISTRICTS DOWN YOU KNOW
THEY- THEY'RE JUST- IF THIS IS
VERY FRUSTRATING TO EVERYBODY
SO WE'VE PUT WE CAN ADDITION TO
THE SIXTY LEADERS AS WE HAVE WE
HAVE ALSO PUT ANOTHER HUNDRED
TWENTY PEOPLE. BACK TO WORK ON
THE CASE WHICH IS AT THE THIRD
THANK YOU SUCH A FUN AFTER THAT
APPRECIATE DR THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT BETWEEN NOW AND
pIMPROVEMENT HAPPENS. THANK YOU
PROPERLY HAD ENOUGH STAFF IN
THE INTERIM TO DEAL WITH THE
INFLUX OF CALLS WE JUST CAN'T.
WE FRANKLY WE CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH IT IS JUST BE REMANDED
STAND BECOME TO MY THINK IT'S
FOR THE BECOME. TOO MUCH FOR
ALL OF OUR OUR DISTRICT STAFF.
SO THANK YOU. AND AS A AS A
FOLLOW UP SIGNS HOW QUICK WILL
LEGISLATIVE STAFF ESPECIALLY
OUR DISTRICT STAFF BE ABLE TO
TRANSFER. THOSE CASE FILES ARE
CASELOADS TO EURO A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY A FULL TIME STAFF AT EDT.
THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY STAFF
WAS STARTED THIS WEEK. WE'RE
GONNA SEE HOW FAST WE CAN YOU
KNOW WE CAN KEEP YOU ABREAST
AND YOUR FOR YOUR STAFF FOR
KEEPING ABREAST OF HOW IT'S
MAKING AN IMPACT- SO YOU KNOW
WE STARTED THIS WEEK ARE YOU
KNOW I'M GOING TO BE CHECKING
ON IT EVERY WEEK WE'LL SEE IF
IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE AND IF
IT. WE NEED TO DO MORE WITH.
THIS IS KEVIN KNOWLEDGE OUT BUT
DECIDED DIRECTOR FOR YOU TO
DEAL. ADD A LITTLE BIT MORE
HERE SO- WE CREATED A SYSTEM
LAST YEAR BE A SALES FORCE TO
WORK WITH YOUR OFFICES AND
HAVING THEM INPUT CASES INTO
THAT IN WHICH THE EDT STAFF
WORKS. YOUR OFFICE HOLDER
OFFICES HAVE BEEN GREAT
PARTNERS ARE NOT PROCESS
CONTINUING TO PUT THOSE CASES
IN THAT SYSTEM TO HAVE THE
STAFF WORK AT. THIS A HUNDRED
TWENTY STAFF OF THE DIRECTORS
MENTIONED WILL BE WORKING
DIRECTLY ON THOSE MORE COMPLEX
CASES BETTER BUT YOUR STAFF FOR
PUTTING IN THE SYSTEM SO
THERE'S- ALREADY A SYSTEM SET
UP TO TRANSFER THAT. AND SO
WE'RE WE'RE ADDING RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS- THOSE CASES THAT HAVE
BEEN BEEN ENCROACHED INTO THE
SYSTEM. SO JUST WANT ONE LAST
FOLLOW UP ON. I NOTICE WITH
YOUR BACKLOG OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE
MADE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS
SINCE FEBRUARY BUT WITH THE
BACKLOG- YOU HAD A LOW OF APRIL
TENTH AND NOW STARTED TO CREEP
BACK UP. ON OUR DID YOU
ANTICIPATE CONTINUED TO BE ABLE
TO BRING THAT BACKLOG BACK DOWN
OR DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO
KEEP GOING. GOING UP I THINK
THAT'S AN OVERALL CONCERN. WHAT
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION- I THINK
I'LL ALECTRA ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES ANSWER THAT MIGHT MY
SENSE IS THAT. WITH THESE
ADDITIONAL HANDS WORKING THE
CASES THAT WE WILL BUT WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE ANY NEW PROGRAMS ARE
AND SO IT'S REALLY IN MY MIND
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE AN
IMPACT BUT A LECTURE CAL STATE.
ANYTHING BUT THAT YEAH I CAROL
WILLIAMS- EDT. I THINK THE
RECTOR SIZE IS DIRECTLY ON
POINT WE ARE WATCHING THESE
NUMBERS ON A AND AGAIN THESE
ARE INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE ARE VERY
SENSITIVE TO THAT ANY
INCREMENTAL INCREASE AND THAT
IS A CONCERN TO US WE'RE
CERTAINLY TRYING TO ROOT CAUSE
EVERY SINGLE WEEK WHAT. WHAT
THE INCREASES WHAT CAN WE DO SO
AT JUST A LITTLE BIT ON THE-
THE BENEFIT YEAR ENDING WHICH
IS HAS BEEN A HUGE GLOBAL
CONCERN THE CLAIMANTS SOMEWHERE
SURPRISE THEY WERE NOT AWARE
THAT LITERALLY THEIRCLAIM MS
IN TWELVE MONTHS- WELL THIS
INFORMATION IS CERTAINLY
AVAILABLE ONLINE WE ARE LOOKING
TO JUST PUSH TAX MESSAGES SO
THAT EVERY SINGLE ONE.
ABSOLUTELY KNOWS A LITTLE BIT
OF TAXING MIGHT NOT ACTUALLY BE
GOING INTO THEIR MESSAGING
ACCOUNT- BUT THEY KNOW YOU KNOW
THEIR CLAIMS OR IN SOME TYPE OF
PENDING STATUS IT HASN'T MOVED
IN THIS IS LITERALLY WHAT THE
BULK OF THE ISSUE IS THAT THERE
YEAR HAS ENDED AND BAIT WE- THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM EITHER THE
IS THAT THEY INITIATE- FILING A
NEW CLAIM WE CERTAINLY ARE
ALSO. LOOKING AT ALL THESE
CLAIMS THAT HAVE EXPIRED AND-
WE'RE IN MICHIGAN INITIATING
THEM ON THE BEHALF OF CLAIMANTS
BUT THERE ARE SO MANY IN FRONT
OF US IT'S SO MUCH FASTER IF
THE CLAIMANT DOESN'T SO THAT'S
THE TEXT MESSAGE THAT'S GOING
OUT MY SAY THOSE TO SHARE-
WE'RE LOOKING TO SEE WHAT THE
ISSUES ARE WE'RE TRYING TO GET
AHEAD BE PROACTIVE WITH
MESSAGING SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
THESE BACKLOG NUMBERS DOWN FOR
THOSE THAT CAN BE RESOLVED. SO
THAT OUR STAFF COULD REALLY
JUST WORK THE MOST DIFFICULT
COMPLICATED. CASES AND- AND
THOUGHT THAT SHE THAT FOLKS
RECEIVE ACCLAIM FOR. THANK
CAN'T MISS CHIU. THANK YOU OUT
WHEN YOU START A MATTER
DIRECTOR BY JUST RECOGNIZING-
WE ALL KNOW HOW DIFFICULT YOUR
JOB IS AND- I WANTED TO SAY I
KNOW HOW HARD YOUR TEAM HAS
BEEN WORKING TO ADDRESS THIS
AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE ALL
THAT WORK I KNOW EVERYONE IS
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
THINGS HAVE BEEN SO DIFFICULT-
I DO WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON SOME
THE QUESTIONS OF OUR CHAIR OF
BOTH OUR SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR AND
OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE CHAIR.
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO SEE MANY OF THE-EXACT SAME UNDERLYING ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE BEEN FLAGGING FOR
THE BETTER PART OF A YEAR AS
WELL AS SIMILAR WAIT TIMES-
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT
THIS PAST WEEKEND MY DISTRICT
OFFICE RECEIVED OVER A HUNDRED
ENQUIRIES FROM CONSTITUENTS WHO
NEED HELP WITH THEIR CASES THIS
MONTH MY OFFICE HAS BEEN
RECEIVING. COUNTLESS CALLS FROM
DESPERATE CONSTITUENTS MANY OF
WHOM WERE IN TEARS SOME OF WHOM
ARE ON THE BRINK OF
HOMELESSNESS AND EVEN SOME WHO
HAVE THREATENED SUICIDE AND WE
KNOW THIS IS JUST A COMPLETELY
UNTENABLE SITUATION FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND COMPLETELY
UNSUSTAINABLE FOR DISTRICT
STAFF SO ON THIS ISSUE OF HOW
IS IT THAT DESPITE ALL OF THE
EFFORTS THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT IS
MADE IN THE INCREASE STAFFING
WE ARE STILL SEEING AN INCREASE
IN THE BACKLOG IT SEEMS TO US
THAT. WE'RE NOT JUST TREADING
WATER BUT WORKS FOR UNDERWATER
AGAIN AND I'M WONDERING DOES IT
HAVE TO DO WITH IT DOT MAYBE
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT ANY
ISSUES THERE IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY'RE CAPACITY ISSUES AROUND
THAT SYSTEM- WE ALSO ARE
HEARING THAT TRAINING OF STAFF
HAS BEEN VERY CHALLENGING
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND THAT-
WOULD JUST WHAT WHAT ARE THE
TOP LEVEL THINGS THAT YOU FEEL
ARE- THE BOTTLENECKS TO BEING
ABLE TO DRESS THE SITUATION AND
I HATE TO ASK THIS QUESTION BUT
I NEED TO. WHICH IS DO YOU IT
IS OUR TIME FRAME FOR WHEN YOU
THINK THESE NUMBERS WILL WILL
COME DOWN ONES. ONE IS THE
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
THE TRUTH I THINK THAT WITH TO
BEGIN TO SEE LIGHT AT THE END
OF. THE TUNNEL PROBABLY AT THE
END OF JUNE. R. BUT I WANT TO
REITERATE A LARGE PART OF THE
SEARCH HAS COME FROM PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HIT THEIR BENEFIT YEAR AND.
AND I'LL JUST GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE SO YOU KNOW OF. NOBODY
CAME UP TO ME AND ASKED ME
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WERE
THEY GONNA DO THEY GOT THEY GOT
THEIR LAST CHECK THEY WERE
WAITING FOR A CHECK. THE CHECK
ACTUALLY SAID ON IT. WHAT WAS
HAPPENING. BUT YOU KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE ARE STRESSED OUT. THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY PAY ATTENTION
TO EVERYTHING. SO I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTOOD WHY THE GENTLEMAN
WAS ASKED ME GOOD SO I SAID IF
YOU HAVE A FEW HAVE. ALREADY
CHECKED YOUR EMAIL BUT IT
REALLY SHOULD BE ON YOUR CHECK.
LATER I SILENCE YES IT WAS ON
MY CHECK I FIGURED IT OUT- BUT
YOU KNOW. THE THIS GUY WAS WAS
PRETTY WELL EDUCATED. WE HAVE
LANGUAGE ACCESS PROBLEMS WHEN
PEOPLE ARE NOT- SAVVY ABOUT.
HOW TO DEAL WITH GOVERNMENT AND
HAVE A LOOK AT HOW TO WORK WITH
FORMS ARE OR THEY THEY JUST
I'VE HAD PEOPLE WHO WHO WROTE
IT SAID. BOB I GOT A MESSAGE
FROM EDT THAT SAYS I DON'T HAVE
TO DO ANYTHING AND I WILL BE
PAID AND MY BACK PAYMENT WILL
BE MADE TO ME. IN WICKS. WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN. EIGHT WHAT ARE
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
PEOPLE AREN'T A LOT OF STRESS
RIGHT NOW SO WE'RE DEALING WITH
IT'S HARD TO GET IN WITH PEOPLE
SOMETIMES ARE OUT FOR THEIR
BEST FOR THEIR OWN BEST
INEREST I THINK THAT THE SURGE
IS PRIMARILY DUE TO THE
DIFFICULTIES OF PEOPLE
UNDERSTANDING. WHY WHY WHY
DIDN'T MY BENEFIT YEAR AND ARE
WHY DO I HAVE TO CERTIFY EVERY
TWO WEEKS I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
CERTIFY IT SHOULD BE AUTOMATIC
USER THE RULES AND REGULATIONS
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. SO
YOU KNOW WITH WITH THESE NEW
THINGS THAT WERE PUT WE'VE ALSO
I DIDN'T MENTION. WE'VE ALSO
LOOKED AT AREAS WHERE WE CAN
AUTOMATE. OUR SOME OF OUR
MANUAL PROCESSES AND WE'VE DONE
SOME OF THAT AS WELL. SO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS THERE ARE
THERE INCREMENTAL IMPROVEMENTS.
YEAH EDT RIGHT NOW YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT I
THINK BY THE SUMMER. THAT'S AND
I UNDERSTAND LISTEN I
UNDERSTAND HOW DESPERATE PEOPLE
ARE. I GET THESE LETTERS I GET
THESE EMAILS. MYSELF DIRECTLY.
SO ARE THERE ISN'T A DAY THAT
THAT GOES BY WITHOUT THIS BEING
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT TO MY FACE.
THE DIFFICULTY THAT PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING. AND I GUARANTEE
YOU EVERYBODY WHO WORKS ON
THESE CLAIMS EDT IS VERY VERY
AWARE OF THAT. ARE STILL
VOLUNTEERING TO WORK THE
WEEKENDS AND IN THE EVENINGS TO
GET THESE KIND OF STUCK. AND WE
WILL HAVE A GREATER.
FORECASTERS TUB QUESTION A
CLARIFICATION QUESTION ON THE
SIZE OF THE BACKLOG- WHEN YOU
GO TO THE MAIN EDT- DATA PAGE
IT SAYS THE BACKLOG OF CLAIMS
PAST TWENTY ONE DAYS PENDING
EDT ACTION IS A HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THE SIZE OF THE BACKLOG AS
WE- TYPICALLY UNDERSTAND IT
WHICH INCLUDES SAY CLOSE TO
MILLION FOLKS WERE BACKLOGGED
BECAUSE THEY'RE WAITING
CERTIFICATION FROM THE CLAIMANT
AND OTHERS THAT THE REAL NUMBER
THE BACKLOG AS WE UNDERSTAND IT
IS CLOSER TO ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION. WONDERING IF YOU COULD
START TALKING ABOUT THAT AND
WONDER IF I THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
SEE THAT MORE CLEARLY BECAUSE
WE AS YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT TO DIG
AROUND TO REALLY. UNDERSTAND
THAT YEAH I THINK THAT THE
PROBLEM THERE THE REASON THAT
YOU'RE SEEING THE- THE
STATISTICS OF THE WAY THEY ARE
NOW WAS THAT THE OTHER
STATISTIC WHEN THEY WERE MERGED
TOGETHER WAS MISLEADING. WHAT
HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
CERTIFIED. FOR THEIR WEEKS. WE
HAVE DONE EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THEM. TO
REMIND THEM TO URGE THEM TO
CERTIFY I COULD NOT MAKE
SOMEBODY CERTIFY. IF I COULD
JUST- INSERT HERE. A LARGE
NUMBER OF CLAIMANTS HAVE FOUND
EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS THE BEST
RESULT BUT THEY WALK AWAY FROM
THE CLIMB BUT WE REFLECT THEIR
CLAIMS UP WITH FULL
TRANSPARENCY ON OUR DASHBOARD
IN ON OUR SYSTEM SO THAT WE
HAVE THE FULL BOUNTY OF THE
WORK INVOLVED BUT IT TAKES
THIRTY DAYS FOR THOSE TO ROLL
OFF BUT IT'S A CONSTANT ROLE.
THANK YOU. FIVE AB I APPRECIATE
THAT I KNOW YOU KNOW THERE
THERE ARE CERTAINLY IN THAT
CATEGORY SAY MILLION FOLKS THAT
HAVE NOT TO- CERTIFIED THERE
ARE DEFINITELY CONSTITUENTS
WHO. ARE CONFUSED WERE
INTERACTING WITH THEM OR TRY TO
GET THEM TO BUT THEY STILL IN
OUR MINDS COUNTED SPOKES THAT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AS PART OF
THE BACKLOG AND I AND I KNOW
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT- ONE THE
TOTAL ASSET QUESTIONS AROUND
LANGUAGE ACCESS- YOU KNOW.
LANGUAGE ACCESS IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR ME AND MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. IT'S AN ISSUE WE'VE
WE'VE DISCUSSED- IT'S EMBODIED
IN MY AB FOUR ONE. BILL TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES- THE
MATTER DIRECTOR YOU GIVE A VERY
BRIEF UPDATE I'M WONDERING IF
YOU COULD ELABORATE- I HEARD. I
THINK I HEARD. FIVE LANGUAGES
THAT YOU'RE PLANNING TO ROLLOUT
BUT OBVIOUSLY THERE. OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND- STATE WONDERING.
WHY YOUR PLANS ARE FOR.
ADDITION LANGUAGES WONDERING
WHAT SORT OF DOCUMENTS AND
UPDATES ARE GONNA BE AVAILABLE
ON THE PORTAL. WHETHER WE WILL
TRULY HAVE AN ONLINE PORTAL-
JUST LOVE IF YOU COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT YOUR
PLANS ARE. YEAH AND- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
DEPARTMENT IN THIS AREA. THIS
AREA IS VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART. ARE YOU HAVING GROWN
UP IN A IN COMMUNITIES WHERE
OUR- CHILDREN. HAVE WERE PUT IN
THE POSITION OF HAVING TO
TRANSLATE. OR FOR ALL THE
FAMILY MEMBERS BECAUSE THERE
WAS. LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY EVEN THOUGH THOSE
PEOPLE WERE WORKING HARD.
MAKING MONEY SUPPORTING THEIR
FAMILIES PAY MORE TAXES. ARE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE. THE LANGUAGES
THAT I MENTIONED. LOOK AT MY
NOTES HERE. WE HAVE IT IN
CHINESE VIETNAMESE. HER THESE
ARE LINES WE ALREADY HAVE
INCIDENTS LIKE THESE ARE NOT
NEW LINES. WHEN I CAME INTO THE
DEPARTMENT WE HAD- BUT WE HAD
LET ME TALK ABOUT ANOTHER IMAGE
OF IT. WE HAD OUR BROOKS OF THE
MINOR CONTRACT FOR.
INTERPRETATION SERVICES WE ARE
NOT SPENDING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON INTERPRETATION. WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
YOUR TRAINING I THINK IT EITHER
ROLLED OUT THIS WEEK OR NEXT
WEEK. TO RE DUCATE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE PHONES
HOW TO USE THAT LANGUAGE ACCESS
FEATURES THAT WE'RE WE HAVE
OUR- INCREASED WE HAVE. WE WILL
HAVE TRANSLATED A NUMBER OF
SIGNIFICANT FORMS ONCE THEIR
CLAIM ISSUES ALL THE TIME. IN
TWO DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND- IN
THIS LANGUAGE PORTAL- LET ME
ASK YOUR WHERE ARE YOU WHAT ARE
TIMELINE ON THE IDEAS I'M SORRY
I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF SHEETS
HERE AND I'M LOOKING FOR THOSE.
THE LANGUAGE OF THE LINES THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TO SERVE
PEOPLE SO THE LANGUAGE I PICKED
UP EARLIER OR ENGLISH SPANISH
MANDARIN CANTONESE AND
VIETNAMESE. RIGHT AND I THINK
THERE'S ONE MORE YEAH. CORRECT
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE CURRENT
DIRECT LINES TODAY RIGHT BUT
I'M GONNA HAVE TO SEE MY
COLLEAGUE NANCY COULD NOT STEP
IN. I NEED A VERY SPEEDY- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THE
QUESTION AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE- AS
THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED SOME OF
THOSE THOSE ARE AS AS YOU
MENTIONED IN THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED THOSE ARE SOME OF
OUR- SHORT TERM GOALS. AND SOME
OF OUR SOME OF OUR LONGER TERM
GOALS DO INCLUDE THE- MULTI
LINGUAL WEB PORTAL. YOU KNOW
THE OF A MULTI LAYER OF. MULTI
LINGUAL ACCESS COORDINATOR
WE'RE LOOKING AT HIRING- ONE OF
THOSE- WE WANT TO EXPAND OUR
YOU WHY ONLINE. THE BENEFIT
APPLICATIONS BE ON JUST
SPANISH- THAT IS YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
REPEATEDLY- AND WE WANT TO OF
COURSE- EXCEPT IN PROCESS IF
YOU WANT ANY- PAPER
APPLICATIONS- BEYOND SPANISH
TO- HOW MANY LANGUAGES THAT WE
HAVE NOW WE HAVE IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY WE HAVE- FORMS
TRANSLATED. ONLINE INTO I
BELIEVE IT'S ELEVEN LANGUAGES
AND I CAN GET TO THAT- THAT
INFORMATION THEY ARE THE MOST
USED IN VITAL- NOTICES THAT WE
HAVE- THE AND I BELIEVE. IT'S
ELEVEN LANGUAGES THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT- I SHOULD SAY I THINK IT
WAS A MEETING OR TWO AGO THAT
THIS COMMITTEE EXPRESSED- OF
OPENNESS TO DISCUSSING FUNDING
OPTIONS TO ENSURE REAL LANGUAGE
ACCESS- THIS COMING YEAR- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WE MIGHT BE
EXPECTING SOME UPDATES IN A
REVISED AND- FORMER HOPE THAT
THAT MIGHT HAPPEN. I THINK
WE'RE ALL LOOKING FORWARD TO IT
TO NEW PROPOSALS AND TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO REALLY LAND SOME
MEANINGFUL SOLUTIONS ON THIS- I
CAN TELL YOU THAT MY BILINGUAL
STAFF. ARE ARE AT WIT'S END.
TRYING TO ADDRESSES SO- JUST
AGAIN APPRECIATE DAT PROJECT
WORK ON THIS MATTER JEFF THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR SUPPORT AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP MISTER COOPER- THANK
YOU I'M- ARE BIG ISSUES THAT
EVERY TIME AN EXTENSION OF
BENEFITS OCCUR. WHICH IS EVERY
TWENTY SIX WEEKS. OUR OFFICE
GETS INUNDATED WITH THE SAME
CONSTITUENTS. ASKING FOR HELP.
WHICH IS ULTIMATELY OPENING
THEIR CASES. BECAUSE THE DELAY
OF BENEFITS WHICH EDIE TOLD US
IS ANYWHERE BETWEEN FOUR AND
SIX WEEKS. WE ALSO- HAVE
MARKETED FROM THE EDT STAFF IS
STILL TOYING OUR CONSTITUENTS
TO CALL. US TO RESOLVE THEIR
CASES. AND RIGHT NOW I FEEL
RESURGENT ABOUT FIFTY SIXTY
CASES PER FIELD REP. SOME
WHAT'S IT TAKING SO LONG STILL
WITH EXTENSION. WE KNOW CAN
MOST OF THE PROGRAMS WE WERE
ABLE TO. GOOD PEOPLE THEIR
BENEFITS WITHOUT INTERRUPTION-
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE CASES
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER- WE'RE
NOT HAPPY WITH THAT TYPE OF-
WITH THOSE TYPE OF STATISTICS
BELIEVE ME. ANDEAVOR WE'RE JUST
GOING TO KEEP WORKING ON THIS
TOUR. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
WOULD HOPE WHAT HAPPENED I'M
GONNA GO BACK TO THE WEBSITE
AGAIN. THAT WEBSITE HAS BECOME
TAKES A LOOK AT THAT IN ANY OF
THOSE PEOPLE CAN BE REFERRED TO
THE WEBSITE. FOR THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED EVEN
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND NOW YOU'RE
BEGINNING TO SEE PETE PEOPLE
CONTENT SAY GO TO THE WEBSITE
IT'S FASTER- THAT'S ALL THAT I
CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THAT
REALLY I'M TELLING YOU WHERE WE
ARE. DOING OUR BEST- ANY IDEAS
YOU HAVE YOU KNOW I TALKED TO A
COUPLE OF LEGISLATORS THAT'S OF
GOOD IDEAS ABOUT. HOW TO HANDLE
THIS. WE'LL BE WORKING WITH YOU
EVEN CLOSER- YOU KNOW AS THESE
ARE AS WE BURN DOWN THESE
APPLICATIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
REALLY THIS IS NOT LOST ON ME
AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
OKAY EARLIER YOU TALKED ABOUT
YOUR IN YOUR NEW FRAUD UNIT IT
WOULD APPEAR SEKHEMRE WE'VE GOT
A WOMAN THAT- THE SHE PROBABLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS AN INMATE AND NON
INMATE RELATED FOUGHT BETWEEN
JAILS AND STATE PRISONS. THE
PUBLIC ET DE IS- THERE'S NO
STRONG CHECKS AND BALANCES THE
CATCHER DEVICE IN FULL FROM
CELL PHONES AND COMPUTERS THAT
ARE FILED. THEY DON'T CAPTURE
IP ADDRESSES WHEN PEOPLE RE
UPPED THEIR CLAIMS- IS THAT
TRUE OR YOU GUYS ARE YOU GUYS
REVAMPING HEALTH YOUR NEW FRAUD
UNIT. SET NEED VARIOUS WITH
EDT- SO. I'M I'M A LITTLE BIT
UNFAMILIAR WITH SOME OF THE
PHONE- EXAMPLE THE PHONE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU GAVE BUT I DO
KNOW THAT- THE I. P. ADDRESS IS
CERTAINLY ONE OF OUR ONE OF OUR-
FRIED CRITERIA. WELL THE SAME
THING IS THE PHONE BECAUSE THE
PHONE WILL HAVE AN ID NUMBER IF
THEY'RE DOING IT FOR ME. I'M
I'M A CELL PHONE ALSO. SO I
MEAN ESPECIALLY WITH MEDIA
FRAUD IN MULTIPLE CASES.
RESIGNING FROM ONE I. P.
ADDRESS SO ARE YOU ABLE TO
CATCH THAT NOW. I MEAN I I'D BE
HAPPY TO TAKE THAT CONVERSATION
OFFLINE SO WE DON'T DISCUSS ALL
OF THE BROAD CRITERIA ONLINE
BUT I'M IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD ASSUME
THAT WE HAVE IF IT IS- IF IT
IS. AS YOU SAY RELATED TO I. P.
ADDRESS RIGHT. IN ORDER TO GET
RID. I'M SORRY GO AHEAD. SO YOU
KNOW WE'RE WORKING WITH- YES.
ON FRIDAY ISSUES. WE HAVE A
TASK FORCE WITH. OTHER DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS WHO WERE WORKING WITH
NOW AS WELL WHICH IS THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
WORKFORCE AGENCIES OUT OF WHICH
EACH IS A PART. AND DEREK IF
YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION OR ANY
IDEA. ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE THAT
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT WE WANT
TO HEAR IT I GUESS THE QUESTION
FOR YOU WHAT EXACTLY IS AND
THEY WORK WITH- YES WHAT
EXACTLY IS- YES DOING. HEY AT
THE VARIOUS WITH WITH- EDT OUT
SO- YES WE'RE EDT IS PART OF A
TASK FORCE WITH- WE ASK THAT
INCLUDES- THE U. S. ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
THE F. B. I.'S CDC ARE. AND
BASICALLY WHAT WE DO IS SHARE
DATA WITH THEM SO WE CAN CATCH
THE CRIMINALS I SUPPOSE IF
THAT'S THE WAY I SHOULD SAY IT-
THERE WAS SOME ISSUES. YOU
KNOW. EIGHT MONTHS AGO I
SUPPOSE- WHERE THE DATA WASN'T
GETTING TO THE UP TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN A TIMELY MANNER
AND TIMELY MANNER SO WE NOW
HAVE A DATA SHARING AGREEMENT
WHERE- ALL THOSE ENTITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE DATA. AND THEY
CAN RECEIVE THE DATA. FINALLY
I'M SO THEY CAN GO AFTER THE
CRIMINALS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
STEALING. ON THE U. ISIS. OKAY
THE OTHERS THIS IS OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION IS PROBABLY
CLOSER TO A BILLION DOLLARS. SO
HAVE YOU RECOVERED ANY
FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS. FROM A
CURSORY INDIVIDUALS- THERE
ACTUALLY WAS- SOME RECOUPING OF
MONEY I DON'T HAVE IT IN FRONT
OF ME BUT IT WAS THROUGH THE- I
BELIEVE IT WAS HROUGH ONE OF
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S WORKING
WITH EDT SOMEONE WAS CONVICTED.
AND WE DID RECOUP SOME OF THAT
MONEY I I'M SORRY I DON'T HAVE
THE AMOUNT IN FRONT OF ME.
EXPENSES DIRECTOR AND I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU WE ARE GOING TO
COLLECT EVERY PENNY WE CAN'T.
IF IT'S NOT SPENT ALREADY-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LISTEN IF
IT'S HIDDEN ANYWHERE IN ANY
ASSETS OR ANYTHING WE WANT THAT
MONEY. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
SCIENCE THANK YOU MISTER COOPER
A MISTER NAZARIAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR UP FIRST BEFORE I
ASK MY QUESTIONS I JUST WANTED
TO TAKE A MOMENT AAIN AND
THANK- DIRECTOR CENTS FOR- THIS
UNDERTAKING I DO I'VE SAID IT
BEFORE BOTH IN OUR PERSONAL
COMMUNICATIONS AS WELL AS IN
THIS COMMITTEE. I DO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE EXPERIENCE YOU
BRING TO THIS AND I DO
APPRECIATE ALSO HOW
OVERWHELMING OF A TASK THIS IS-
AND- I THINK WHATEVER PARK.
COLLEAGUES ARE ASKING IS TO
HELP PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
SUPPORT AND AMMUNITION YOU NEED
BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
INFORMATION SHARING IS WHAT'S
GONNA ALLOW US TO BETTER GET TO
A SOLUTION- SO BEFORE I ASK MY
QUESTIONS JUST TO PIGGYBACK ON
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO FROM MISTER COOPER
WAS ASKING. HAVE YOU DONE
FORENSICS TO SEE FOR EXAMPLE
HOW MANY OF THE CHECKS THAT
WERE ARONIE ASLI OR
FRAUDULENTLY. MAILED OUT AND
RECEIVED HOW MANY OF THEM HAVE
ALREADY BEEN CASHED SET LIST
THAT WE WERE WORKING BACKWARDS
AND BLOCKING THE ONES THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN CASHED YET WHAT KIND
OF WORK HAS BEEN DONE TO SEE TO
WHAT EXTENT WE CAN STOP THE
BLEEDING. FOR HER FOR HER. GET
ANY NUMBERS ON THAT DOES ANYONE
HAVE ANY NUMBERS ON THAT. THIS
IS DIRECTOR SIGNED SO. LET ME
STATE THAT WELL WE CAN PROVIDE
IDENTIFICATION TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE ARE NOT IN
INVESTIGATIONS. ORGANIZATION
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WE WORK OUT WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S AND THE FBI
AND HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW ANY
OTHER NATIONAL. OF PRODUCT
ORIENTED ORGANIZATIONS SO IT
WOULDN'T BE IT WOULDN'T BE E.
D. D. THAT WOULD HAVE THAT
INFORMATION IT WOULD BE OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS. AT IF I
MAY INTERRUPT FOR A MINUTE I
RESPECT THAT AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I HOPE I'M NOT ASKING
ANYTHING THAT REVEALS TOO MUCH
WHAT I'M SPECIFICALLY ASKING IS
THAT THE BANK A PATH ACCOUNTS
THAT ARE THAT THE EDT CHECKS
ARE DISPERSED FROM OUR UNDER
YOUR PURVIEW AND CONTROL. SO
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO DETERMINE.
THESE CHECKS THAT HAVE BEEN
FRAUDULENTLY ISSUED HOW MANY OF
THEM HAVE EVEN BEEN CASHED. DO
WE KNOW THAT. VARIOUS WITH THE
EIGHTIES SO I DON'T HAVE A
NUMBER OF HOW MANY HAVE BEEN
CASH VERSUS HAVE NOT BEEN CASH
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU ENOUGH I
THINK YOU KNOW WE PROBABLY SAY
THE SAME- INFORMATION- YOU KNOW
THAT WHERE EDT IN THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S WORK TOGETHER ON A
CASE AND YOU KNOW THAT OR
SOMETHING YOU KNOW WHERE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S WILL SEE
THEY'RE DOING AN INVESTIGATION
YOU KNOW BASED ON INFORMATION
THAT YOU DD HAS PROVIDED TO
THEM. AND THERE ARE MULTIPLE
CHECKS OR MULTIPLE CARDS THAT
ARE- OBTAINED FROM YOU KNOW
INDIVIDUAL'S HOW THE STORE OR
WHATEVER- AND SO WE DO. HOW
THOSE YOU KNOW AS A RECORD IF
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE ASKING OKAY
SO DO WE KNOW OF THE NUMBER OF
FRAUDULENT. CHECKS ISSUED- SO
WE ARE ALL PART THAT
INFORMATION RIGHT NOW- SO YOU
KNOW WE HAD EARLIER THIS YEAR
AS YOU REMEMBER WE HAD THE
FRAUD NUMBERS THAT WE WORKED
WITH THAT- AUDITOR ON ENGINE
AND WHILE THAT WHILE WE HAD
THAT NUMBER WE WERE THERE WAS
THAT ONE POINT FOUR EIGHT
MILLION- SPOT THAT WAS PENDING
AND SO THAT THOSE NUMBERS WE
ARE UPDATING THOSE NUMBERS AND
TO JUST TAKE TO GO ALONG WITH
THAT- YOU KNOW IT AND I KNOW
WE'VE SAID THIS AND ASK
COMMITTEE HEARINGS WHERE- WE
ARE NOW WORKING WITH ONE OF OUR
VENDOR PARTNERS EXTEND SURE. TO
DO AN ANALYSIS ON ALL OF THE
FRAUD TO FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW IT
TOO ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER IS-
EARLIER POINT YOU KNOW WHAT
SOME OF THE CRITERIA IS THAT
SHOULD BE USED SHOULD NOT BE
USED SHOULD BE REFINED- WE WILL
HAVE THAT THAT'S SOMETHING.
THAT THEY'RE WORKING ON RIGHT
NOW AS WE SPEAK. FRIEDMAN IS
THERE AND I DO WANT TO SAY THIS
I HOPE ARMY- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT IDEA. AND I
WANT TO TELL YOU THAT WHEN WE
LEAVE THESE HEARINGS. WE TAKE
ANY IDEA THAT YOU OFFER US. AND
WE TAKE A LOOK AT WHETHER OR
NOT IT WILL ASSIST YOU IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA SO. WELL WE
CAN'T WE CAN'T ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION RIGHT NOW I WANNA LET
YOU KNOW THAT YEAH I
APPRECIATE. THE SUGGESTION.
OKAY WELL THEN WE'LL LOOK AT
THAT THANK YOU I WOULD HOPE
THAT I WOULD GET AN ANSWER
FROM- FROM YOU MISDIRECT HER.
AT SOME POINT IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE THAT WILL ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES SHOULD BE RECEIVING
BECAUSE SOMETIMES THE BEST WAY
OF DEALING WITH SOMETHING.
OBVIOUSLY IS TO WORK BACKWARDS
AND SEE WHERE YOU CAN STOP THE
BLEEDING- BUT THAT WAS THAT WAS
I WASN'T EVEN INTERESTED IN
ASKING THAT QUESTION THAT WAS
JUST A FOLLOW TO MY COLLEAGUE'S
QUESTION BECAUSE I WANTED TO
SEE- IF WE HAVE. APPROACHED IT
INVERSELY TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE. SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THAT ANSWER. I JUST WANTED
TO POINT OUT A FEW THINGS AND
THIS IS IN LINE WITH THE
QUESTION I JUST ASKED ANYWAY
SO. SOME OF THE EVENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN THRUST ON YOU. ARE
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE. BUT THE
PREPARATION FOR THINGS YOU
ANTICIPATE. SHOULDN'T BE
CONTRIBUTING TO NEW PROBLEMS.
SO IT IN IN IN THAT SPIRIT WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT IS FOR
EXAMPLE YEAH THE VIDEO
EXPLANATIONS. OF FOR THE U. I.
CLAIMS THAT WHOSE BENEFIT JUST
ENDED IN MID MARCH. THE VIDEO
EXPLANATIONS AND FROM YOUR
OFFICE WERE PUBLISHED APRIL
SEVENTH. WHICH WERE PRETTY
CREATED A THREE WEEK DELAY
WHICH MEANS THAT DURING THAT
THREE WEEK PERIOD A LOT OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WERE CALLING OUR
OFFICES- AND ASKING. HOW TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD N. N. AND
PLACING A NEW CLAIM. SO WHEN
YOU ANTICIPATE A CERTAIN
DEADLINE APPROACHING A CERTAIN
TIMELINE COMING WHEN YOU CAN
DOVE TAIL YOUR NEW PROGRAM OR
NEW PROJECT. THAT SHOULD
ALREADY BE ANTICIPATED AND THE
ROLL OUT OF THAT SHOULD HAPPEN
SIGNIFICANTLY. LONGER PERIOD
BEFORE SO THAT YOU YOU ARE
ALREADY ADDRESSING.
CONSTITUENTS QUESTIONS BEFORE
THEY EVEN HAVE TO NOT GET BEAT
DOWN OUR DOORS HOWEVER I WAS
AND- IS THE FIRST THING TO HEAR
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
TALK ABOUT A HUNDRED CALLS
DURING THE WEEKEND. AS I'VE
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY TO YOU
GUYS RECENT AS OUR PHONE
CONVERSATION FROM TWO WEEKS AGO
BUT I'M STILL AVERAGING ABOUT
FORTY CALLS A DAY. JUST FROM
PEOPLE RENEWING. AND THIS IS
BEEN GOING ON SINCE MARCH SO-
YOU KNOW THE APPEAL BACKLOG IS
ALSO ABOUT EIGHT TO TEN WEEKS.
FROM WHAT WE'RE BEING TOLD BY
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE CALLING
OUR OFFICE- AND THE- THE
CLAIMANT INTERVIEW BACKLOG IS A
TEN WEEK WAIT. AND THE WE'VE
WE'VE HAD CONSTITUENTS COLLISON
TELUS THAT THAT THEY'VE BEEN
WINNING. SO I JUST WANTED TO
POINT OUT SOME OF THESE THINGS
BECAUSE- AND BY THE WAY WENT
WHEN YOU WERE EXPLAINING A
LITTLE WHILE AGO ABOUT THE
EXAMPLE OF A- OF A CONSTITUENT
NOT READING THEIR CHECK I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT NOT ALL.
PAYMENTS ARE RECEIVED THROUGH A
CHECK OH NO ABSOLUTELY NOT SOME
OF THE PAYMENTS AS YOU WELL
KNOW ARE COMING ESPECIALLY THE
ONES FROM BE OF A ARE
AUTOMATICALLY DEPOSITED AND SO.
HOW THE COMMUNICATION BE AT
THAT POINT. I'M ASSUMING IT
WOULD BE AN EMAIL ACCOUNT. I
LOOKED THROUGH THE EMAIL NEVER
COME OUT THROUGH THE EMAIL
ACCOUNT. AND THROUGH THE TEXT.
I WISH WE WERE AT A PLACE WHERE
I COULD ASK YOU OF THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU ARE COMMUNICATING BY
TEXT. WHAT ARE YOU WHAT KIND OF
RESPONSE ARE YOU SEEING FROM
THAT ARE THOSE THE ONES THAT
CONTINUE THEN TRYING TO MAKE
PHONE CALLS. OR ARE IN THE
BOTTLE NECK CONTRIBUTING TO THE
BOTTOM BACK OR BECAUSE THEY
RECEIVED THE TAXED ARE THEY NOT
CONTRIBUTING TO THE BOTTLENECK
I MEAN IT'S WE'RE WE'RE NOT
EVEN IN A PLACE WHERE WE CAN BE
DISCUSSING SOME OF THESE
FORENSICS AND THAT'S WHAT'S
VERY TROUBLING TO ME. DIRECTOR-
SO. AGAIN I'M I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
COLLABORATION I WOULD VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE SOME OF THESE
ANSWERS AND ALSO SOME OF THE-
ANSWERS TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE HAD PREVIOUSLY. PROVIDED YOU
WITH THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. LIKE IT DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION HOWEVER I HAVE NO
QUESTION I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE FRUSTRATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN CLEARLY EXPRESSED BY. MY
COLLEAGUES AND HERE'S THE
BIGGEST FRUSTRATION THAT I
WOUL- JUST SHARE. IN BEHALF OF
THOSE IN MY DISTRICT THAT-
CONTINUALLY. AS AN THE
CASELOADS ARE. QUITE
GARGANTUAN- AND I KNOW YOU'RE
DOING THE BEST YOU CAN BUT WE
HAVE TO BE BETTER MAN WE JUST
HAVE TO BE BETTER AND I'D SAY
THE BIGGEST FRUSTRATION THAT I
HAVE IS ONCE WE WORK THROUGH A
PROBLEM WITH THE CONSTITUENT.
THE BEST ANSWER THEY GET IS
IT'S GOING TO BE WEEKS. BEFORE
THEY GET. ANY KIND OF- INCOME.
AND THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT. I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DESCRIBE IT
ANY BETTER IT I MEAN I CALL
AGAIN DECADE THAT SUICIDAL
RIGHT THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
EXTREMELY DESPERATE. MANY OF
WHICH HUNDREDS THAT WE CONTACT
HAVE NO OUTSIDE SUPPORT NETWORK
THEY DON'T HAVE FAMILIES THEY
DON'T HAVE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER WAY.
TO OF EACH. AND WHEN YOU'RE
TOLD THAT THE INCOME THAT
YOU'RE- IT SHOULD BE PROVIDED
BY THE GOVERNMENT. IS WEEKS
AWAY IT'S A HORRIBLE SATURATION
FOR OUR PEOPLE TO EXPRESS THAT
TO THE CONSTITUENCY AND WE'VE
GOT TO DO BETTER AN
ACCELERATION OF- PAYMENTS ONCE
WE IDENTIFY THAT- PAYMENT IS
DUE AND I HOPE WE CAN FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO DO THAT. I AGREE
WITH YOU. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT EVERY DAY. OUR OUR
OUR I DON'T WANT ANYBODY TO GET
THE IMPRESSION. THAT THERE ARE
THERE'S ANY SELF SATISFACTION
HERE WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS- WE
ARE NOT SATISFIED WITH THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE TODAY.
THAT YOU JUST ARE. THE STORIES
ARE ARE TERRIBLE- AND IT'S A
PART OF WHAT PROPELS US FORWARD.
SO I HEAR EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING I'M IN COMPLETE
AGREEMENT WITH YOU YOU'LL GET
NO ARE. NO DEFENSOR EXCUSES
FROM ME WE'RE JUST GOING TO
KEEP WORKING TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN SO THAT PEOPLE GET THE
BENEFITS THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU MISTER LUCKY I THINK
YOU DIRECTOR SIGNS WE DO HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL FOLLOW UPS AS
WELL. AND I ASK YOU ABOUT.
ATTRITION AT EDT HOW MANY
PEOPLE WERE HIRED AND TRAINED
AND HOW MANY WORKERS HAVE LEFT.
THE DEPARTMENT. YOU KNOW THAT'S
A GOOD QUESTION. I CAN'T GIVE
YOU THE SPECIFIC DETAILS. BUT I
CAN TELL YOU THIS ABOUT BECAUSE
OF MY EXPERIENCE WITH CALL
CENTERS. BOTH IN THE PUBLIC AND
THE PRIVATE SECTOR. CALL
CENTERS USUALLY EXPERIENCE A
TURNOVER OF AT LEAST A THIRD
EVERY YEAR. SO THAT THAT IS-
THAT'S A INDUSTRY STANDARD- IT
HAPPENS YOU KNOW WHETHER YOU'RE
WORKING FOR XEROX OR- UNDERWENT
ARE. EDT AT THE- WE DON'T HAVE
THE INFORMATION ON HOW MANY
PEOPLE I JUST DON'T HAVE IT
RIGHT OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
OUT OF ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT
THE OTHER THING OF COURSE IS
THAT WEHAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
RETIREMENTS AS ELL THIS IS YOU
KNOW. IT'S THIS WHOLE
EXPERIENCE I'M I'M- NO ONE CAN
MINIMIZE THE DIFFICULTY THAT
THIS IS BECAUSE FOR SOME OF OUR
CLIENTS. BUT IT ALSO CREATED A
LOT OF PRESSURE FOR OUR STAFF
AS WELL. AND ARE YOU KNOW A
YEAR OF THIS WAS ARE JUST TOO
MUCH FOR SOME PEOPLE. CURRENTLY
LOCKED DR SIDES IF I MAY YES
CAROLING CD SO APPY. OUTSIDE OF
THE PANDEMIC I THINK WE'VE FOR
PREVIOUSLY REPORTED THAT THE
BABY HAD A WORKFORCE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WORK
FORCE OF ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY STAFF FROM
THAT THIS WAS THE STAFF WORKING
YOU ARE PRODUCTION NOT THE
LEADERSHIP TEAM. SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN- AS YOU ALL KNOW
WE HAVE- FOURTEEN
RECOMMENDATION WAS A STOP
HIRING WE CAME THROUGH THAT WE
HAVE BEEN EARNESTLY. TRYING TO
SIT AND HAVE A MORE SUSTAINABLE
BUSINESS OPERATION- SINCE
REALLY THE BEGINNING OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. SO SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN WE HAVE HIRED
FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO EMPLOYEES IN YOUR
LIFE. AT THAT OCCUR- THIRTEEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN HAVE LEFT
SO THAT'S YOUR QUESTION
REGARDING NUTRITION AND I BILL
DO BELIEVE THAT'S ABOUT 25% AND
THAT IS HOW IT IS VERY AS YOU
ALL KNOW THE ISSUES THAT ON
YOUR STAFF OR DEALING WITH OUR
STAFF TO DEAL WITH EVERY DAY
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK- THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE SHIP IN OVERTIME IT
IS VERY STRESSFUL TIME BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY MORE STRESSFUL FOR
CLIENTS THAT WE BELIEVE IN THAT
STATE AT THE FOREFRONT OF OUR
HEART SO IT HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING TO HIRE IT'S BEEN
MORE CHALLENGING TO RETAIN- BUT
IT CONTINUES TO BE WHAT WE'RE-
CURRENTLY WORKING ON IN TERMS
OF RECRUITMENT AND THE
ENVIRONMENT WITH AN EDT. SO I
HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION
IT DOES THANK YOU SO THAT SENT
OUT ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY STAFF ORIGINALLY
ADORABLE HIRED A FOUR THOUSAND
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
BRINGING IT TO A TOTAL OF FIVE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TO WIN THE ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
THAT LEFT. CORRECT COULD THAT'S
MORE THE ORIGINAL STAFF THAT
YOU HAD SO I'M I'M IMAGINING
THAT THERE'S ALSO SOME
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE THAT
ALSO LEFT HARTMAN. ABSOLUTELY
AND WHAT IF THEY'RE THAT HAVE
SURVIVED THROUGH- THEY ARE
PHENOMENAL THEY FOR THEY ARE
AND THEY ARE FULLY FULLY
COMMITTED THE CONTRITION TENDS
TO BE WITH SOME OF THE NEWER
STAFF BUT IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
IT'S HARD TO TELL IT'S COMPLEX-
IT'S PRETTY GRUELING AND- IF.
IT IF THEY'RE NOT MADE FOR IT
IS IT IS CAN BE HEARTBREAKING
ABSOLUTELY STRESSFUL. SEVEN I
HAVE MY SECOND QUESTION WAS
GOING TO BE WHAT'S THAT HOW ARE
THE HOW OR THE ACTUAL WORKERS
AFFECTED BY THE VOLUME OF WORK
AND HOW ARE THEY MANAGING A
NIGHT AND I AM BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE I ALSO DO WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU. TO YOU AND TO
YOUR STAFF AND TO EVERYONE AT
EDT I KNOW THAT IT IS HARD AND
DIFFICULT AND THAT DOESN'T GO
UNNOTICED AND I KNOW THAT OUR
DISTRICT STAFFS ARE ALSO AT
CAPACITY AS WELL. AND SO I'M
WONDERING IF YOU GOT TO SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. HOW THE
WORKERS ARE DOING. I IT IS IT'S
BETTER TO. FROM FOR THEMWE
HEAR FROM THEM EVERY SINGLE
DAY- BUT- WELL WE ARE STILL IN
A PANDEMIC ORGANIZATIONALLY WE
HAVE MADE THE DECISION THAT WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO DO WHAT HAS
ALWAYS WORKED WORK BEST. NOT
ONLY THE EDB BUT IN ANOTHER
SUCCESSFUL ENVIRONMENT AND THAT
IS THE TEAM BUILDING THE TEAM
WORK THE TRAINING THAT HAD BEEN
SUSPENDED FOR ABOUT EIGHT
MONTHS THOSE ARE REALLY IT'S
NOT TRAINING JUST TO TRAIN.
BOTH THE TRAINING THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO EMPLOYEES IT HELPS
THEM BASICALLY SURVIVE IT HELPS
THEM CONTINUE THEIR MARKET
STRENGTHENED THEIR MOTIVATION
THEIR COMMITMENT TO THE MISSION
SO WE HAVE REINSTITUTED
TRAINING- TEAM MEETINGS STAFF
MEETINGS ALL OF THIS HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN PUT ON THE
WAYSIDE IN THE SHELF SO WE
COULD GET DIRECT FULL TIME
PRODUCTION WHILE THAT IS STILL
PARAMOUNT. EMPLOYEES ARE ALSO
PARAMOUNT BECAUSE THE HEALTHIER
THEY ARE THE BETTER THAT THEY
ARE PROVIDING SERVICE TO THE
PUBLIC. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND- THIS IS THIS THE DIRECTOR
SO I JUST WANTED TO- THANK YOU
FOR THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE
STAFF I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
FOR SOME PEOPLE I FOR MANY
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN A DURING.
THIS THIS STARTED. OUT THIS IS
A CALLING. AND THAT'S THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE STATE AND
SUPPORT THEIR YOUR COLLEAGUES
TO STAY AS WELL. THANK YOU I
KNOW THAT IN THE PAST WE HAVE
DISCUSSED- SOME VACANCIES WITH
THE WITH EDT AND I AM I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON ENSURING
THAT. THOSE VACANCIES ARE
FILLED IS THERE A- A U. I.
CHIEF OR AS A DIRECTOR THAT
STRICTLY FOCUS UPON YOU I. YES
THERE IS. A BAND JOB CAROL
SINCE YOU HIRED GOODNESS YEP.
BY YOU MIGHT WANT TO JUST GIVE
A LITTLE BACKGROUND ON HER. SET
MY PLEASURE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION WE HAVE HIRED GRACIE
A- STATEN SHE IS FROM THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT- SHE HAS
PRIOR KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE.
WHAT IS YOUR CAREER STARTED AT
EDT SO SHE HAS EDT- DISABILITY
INSURANCE AS WELL AS
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. SO SHE-
BEGAN EARLY CAREER AT EDT YOU
WHY ALL THE WAY THROUGH I
BELIEVE THE- THE MID LEVEL
WHERE THEY- WERE THEY WOULD
COME AND EAT PR'S WHERE THEIR
EXPERT TECHNICIANS AND CLAIM
FILING. BEGAN HER MANAGERIAL
EXPERIENCE AND THEN MOVED ON.
TO BE AN EXECUTIVE AT THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT. AND WE ARE
SO GREAT TO HAVE HER BACK US
IT'S LIKE COMING HOME SHE HAS
PULLED RIGHT IN I BELIEVE HER
START DATE WAS BEGINNING OF
MARCH MARCH APRIL BEGINNING OF
APRIL SORRY- WE DID ANNOUNCE IT
TO THE PUBLIC BECAUSE OF IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HAVE THAT
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP. FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND SHE
HAS HIT THE GROUND RUNNING AND
SHE'S ABLE TO UNDERSTAND ALL
THE PROGRAMS HE'S. HAPPY
INTRODUCED HER TO YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT I WASN'T AWARE
BUT IT'S GOOD THAT WE ARE NOW
IN A POSITION WHERE THOSE
POSITIONS ARE BEING FILLED AND-
CAN- CAN REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
JUST THE IMPROVEMENTS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT AS WE LOOK
FORWARD AND- GET INTO- MAY
REVISE CONVERSATIONS. I HAVE A
QUESTION REGARDING THE- THE
CONTRACT RELATED TO BENEFIT
INSURANCE AND I KNOW MISTER
NECESSARY AND BROUGHT IT
BROUGHT IT UP A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER TODAY BUT WELL THE NEW
CONTRACT FOR BENEFIT BENEFIT
ISSUANCE OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE INCLUDE A PROVISION
FOR DIRECT DEPOSIT. THE VARIOUS
WITH ADD YES IT WILL AND WE ARE
NOT WAITING FOR THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT DIRECT DEPOSIT AS WE
SPEAK. GREAT OPTIONS ON DIRECT
DEPOSIT. THAT'S GREAT TOO ODD
THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PANEL AS WE MOVE FORWARD WELL I
JUST UGH SEEING NINE I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR-
PROVIDING US NECESSARY
INFORMATION I THINK- THERE ARE
SOME QUESTIONS THAT ARE LEFT
OUTSTANDING THAT WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THE BUDGET BUDGET STAFF-
GETS TO USE THAT WE GET SOME
PROPER RESPONSES AS WE CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD. I WANT TO MAKE
IT VERY CLEAR- I ACTUALLY HAD
ONE MORE QUESTION A RELATED TO
THE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ADDITIONAL STAFF IT'S UNCLEAR
HOW THAT DIRECTION WAS GIVEN TO
THE LEGISLATURE CAN YOU PROVIDE
US WITH- JUST SOME BASIC
INFORMATION IN TERMS OF HOW IS
IT COMMUNICATED TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NEW STAFF WERE AVAILABLE
WITH THAT INFORMATION GIVEN TO
OUR LEADERSHIP OR TWO CHIEFS OF
STAFF OR HOW WHAT IS THE
PROCESS IN WHICH- LEGISLATIVE
OFFICES WILL BE ABLE TO
LITERALLY HAND OVER CASE WORK-
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
ON TO THESE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY. NEW STAFF MEMBERS AND
HOW WILL THE PROCESS WORK
MOVING FORWARD WOULD EACH
OFFICE RECEIVED ONE STAFF SINCE
THERE'S A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY. LEGISLATORS SO THIS
IS KEVIN WITH STRICTER JEDEDIAH
SPEAK TO THAT- SO THE HUNDRED
TWENTY STOPS WILL BE ADDED TO
THE SIXTY STAFF BETTER. WORK ON
LEGISLATIVE REFERRALS FULL TIME
SAME PROCESS WORKING ON THE
COMPLEX CASES- BUT- SUBMITTED
INTO THE CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. THAT WE HAVE TRAINED
OFFICERS ON HOW TO INPUT CASES
ON. SO I GET THE LINE UP WITH A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY OFFICES BUT THAT'S JUST
A COINCIDENCE BUT- BUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY STAFF. ARE
COMING FROM THE U. I BRANCH.
OUT TO WORK ON THOSE MORE
COMPLEX CASES THE FEEDBACK
WE'VE BEEN GETTING WAS. HOPING
FOR MORE RESPONSIVENESS ON
THOSE CASES IN PARTICULAR SO
WORKING TO ADDRESS THAT-
SEVERAL OUT WAS SHARED WITH-
LEADERSHIP BY ANNOUNCED IT ON
OUR- I WEEKLY LETTERS CALL THAT-
ALL OFFICE. ARE INVITED TO WE
OFTEN HAVE OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PARTICIPANTS ON THAT
CALL. SO TRY TO GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT THERE BECAUSE
WANTED TO ASSURE OFFICES THAT
SOME HELP WAS COMING. AND
COMMUNICATE THAT THAT CHANGE TO
THEM. CAN YOU PROVIDE ME WITH
LET ME JUST EXPLAIN THAT. THOSE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY PEOPLE WILL
BE IN THE BACKGROUND WORKING
WITH THE LIAISONS AND WORKING
ON ANY CASES. THAT HAVE BEEN
STANDING THERE FOR AWHILE. IT
IS. WE HAVE FOUND THAT IS NOT A
GOOD IDEA TO. SHIFT OR CHANGE
LIAISONS WITH THE OFFICE OF
THAT USUALLY RESULTS IN OUR
SOME AMOUNT OF UPSET BECAUSE
PEOPLE LIKE THEIR LIAISONS. SO
THESE HUNDRED TWENTY PEOPLE
WILL HELP THOSE LIAISONS- GET
THOSE CASES RESULT. AND I JUST
UNLESS YOU HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION- MADAM CHAIRMAN. I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY. THAT THIS
HEARING. AS PRODUCED THE RESULT
THAT I HAD HOPED FOR I THINK
THAT WE HAVE HAD. A VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT AND
SOME SUGGESTIONS AND I HAVE
ALWAYS FOUND LEGISLATORS
WILLING TO GIVE ME IDEAS I
THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF THESE
IDEAS ARE VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
DEBT WE WILL TAKE THIS BACK
AND- THIS EXPERIENCE BACK IN
THESE QUESTIONS BACK AND USE
THEM. TO IMPROVE WHAT WE'RE
DOING. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
SCIENCE WE'RE NOT QUITE DONE OF
MR CHIU AND I HAVE ALSO HAVE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO THE TO
THE LIAISON FOR. BUT BUT JUST
ONE FALLS IN THE POINT OF THAT
THE LIAISONS AND FIRST OF ALL.
THAT IS INCREDIBLY WELCOME NEWS
I THINK WE HEARD SOME RUMORS
THAT THAT MIGHT BE HAPPENING
BUT APPRECIATE HEARING THAT-
TODAY IN PUBLIC- I. UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU WANT TO WORK WITH YOUR
LIAISONS I WOULD JUST SUGGEST.
I THINK THE EXPERIENCE OF MANY
OF OUR OFFICES IS THAT OUR
LIAISONS- ONLY. INTERFACE WITH
OUR OFFICES FOR A LIMITED
PERIOD OF TIME SO IT'S A SET
NUMBER OF HOURS A WEEK. AND I
THINK THE HOPE OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ADDITIONAL STAFFERS IS
AT. OUR OFFICES WOULD BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THEM FORTY HOURS A
WEEK- AND ENGAGING IN THAT WAY
AS OPPOSED TO POTENTIALLY BEING
BOTTLENECK THROUGH. THE LIAISON
WHO MAY NOT BE INTERFACING WITH
OUR OFFICE FORTY HOURS A WEEK
SO. THAT JUST WANT TO SUGGEST
THAT THE MORE. I THINK WE CAN
EMBED. THOSE NEW STAFF IN OUR
OFFICES THAT WOULD REALLY.
REALLY HELP. IT'S A IT'S A PLEA.
THANK YOU MR CHIU I DIRECTOR
SIGNS I WOULD HIGHLY HIGHLY
ENCOURAGE YOU AND YOUR TEAM I
THINK THAT YOU WOULD FIND
GRATITUDE FROM THE LEGISLATURE
IF IT'S ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FROM OUR STAFF WE HAVE WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE DOING THE WORK OF
SERVING OUR DISTRICT AND THE
REALITY IS THAT WITH OUR
DISTRICT STAFF MOST OF THE
TIME. DEALING WITH EDT CASES
THAT'S NOT IN THEIR JOB PER
VIEW FOR THE PAST YEAR A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS THAT THEY SHOULD
BE FOCUSED ON- ISN'T GETTING
DONE FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF WORK RELATED TO HELPING
SMALL BUSINESSES WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF WORK TO ENSURE THAT A
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO BE
ABLE TO PAY BACK THEIR RENT A
LOT OF- A GOLDEN STIMULUS.
AGENDA ITEMS THAT WE HAVE MOVED
FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE THRIVING BUT
THAT ALSO MEANS THAT OUR
DISTRICT STAFF IN OUR DISTRICT
TEAMS. ARMS HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO REACH
OUT TO OUR CONSTITUENTS AS THEY
NORMALLY WOULD BECAUSE THEY'RE
WORKING ON VERY IMPORTANT EDT
CASES. WHICH IS NOT
TRADITIONALLY THEIR JOB SO WE
STILL HAVE RESPONSIBILITIES IN
OUR OFFICE THAT WE NEED TO
ENSURE GET TAKEN CARE OF. AND
THAT UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT
GETTING THE PRIORITY THAT IT
DESERVES. BECAUSE OUR STAFFS
ARE WORKING ON EDT CASES. SO I
WOULD JUST ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER REDIRECTING. THE WAY
IN WHICH THOSE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT FULL TIME STAFF
MEMBERS WILL BE PARTICIPATING
BECAUSE THE LIAISONS ARE NOT
ENOUGH. IT'S A PART TIME
POSITION AND THE REALITY IS
THAT IT'S OUR DISTRICT STAFF
THAT CONTINUES TO DO THE WORK
OF EDT AND THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE ANYMORE AT THIS
POINT. SO WE REALLY NEED TO
FIGURE THIS OUT IN A REAL WAY.
SO THAT AGAIN. OUR DISTRICT
TEAMS AND STAFF THE CONTINUES
TO WORK ON EDT CASES WHICH IS
NOT THEIR JOB. I HAVE SOME KIND
OF. GOAL AND MEASUREMENT IN
WHICH THOSE CASES. WILL BE
TAKEN OVER BY EDT. AND OUR
STAFF WILL BE RELIEVED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE DUTIES THAT
THEY- HAVE BEEN HIRED TO DO. TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS OF OUR
DISTRICTS AND OUR AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE- ARE MEANT
TO SERVE. OKAY THANK YOU SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
I KNOW THAT IT IS INCREDIBLY
TOUGH SITUATION AS WE CONTINUE
TO MOVE THROUGH THIS LET JUST
LET LEGISLATIVE CYCLE THANK YOU
AGAIN THANK YOU EVERYONE WE CAN
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO-
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ENTERPRISE DATA TO REVENUE
PROJECT OUR PANELISTS INCLUDE.
JAN A HERRIMAN- BRIAN
WEATHERFORD. DEREK SIMONS AND
CHRIS HILL LET'S BEGIN. AND
THEN MY NAME IS JEANNIE HERMAN
FCB CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER.
AFTER THIS FIRST ISSUE FOR
DISCUSSION IS THE PIECE YOU CAN
SPEND FINANCED LETTER
SUPPORTING THE ENTERPRISE DATA
REVENUE BASED YOU R. ET RG
PROJECT. THANK YOU FOR HAVING A
GENDER RIGHT UP THE PROVIDES
INFORMATION ON THE GOALS OF THE
STATUS OF THE PROJECT. VIDAK
HUH YOU'RE TO PROJECT GETS
SCHEDULED TO BEGIN JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WITH FINAL
APPROVAL RECEIVED ON STAGE TAKE
PART. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY ON
APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND WE'RE NEXT. FOURTEEN THE
ACTUAL CONTRACT IN JUNE OF
TWENTY ONE. IT'S LIKE. SUPPORT
THE REQUESTED TO FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION INCLUDING TWENTY
PERMANENT POSITIONS ARE
PERMANENT INTERMITTENT
POSITIONS I'M THIRTEEN LIMITED
TERM POSITION. THE RESOURCES
REQUESTED IN THE SPRING BINANCE
LETTER OR IN ADDITION TO THOSE
REQUESTED IN THE BUDGET CHANGE
FOR HOLES WILL. NOW THAT THE
PROCUREMENT CASE HAS WRAPPED UP
THIS SPRING FINANCED LETTER
RECONCILES ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCE NEEDS FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY JAIL ABOUT THOSE
PREVIOUSLY REQUESTED. THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTED ADDITIONAL
THIRTY TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
IN FUNDING INCLUDING FUNDING
FOR ONE ADDITIONAL PERMANENT
POSITION. THE REMAINDER IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE INCREASED
EXPECTED PENDER COMPENSATION
COST. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HAVE TO BE EMBARKED ON A
PROJECT A THIRTY YEAR JOURNEY
TO UPDATE OUR TAX SYSTEMS AND
JUNE OF TWENTY SIXTEEN WE
COMPLETED THE FIRST THREE
STAGES ON THIS JOURNEY WITH
FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF
DELIVERABLES UNDER THE GETTING
OUR PROJECT. SEPARATELY A
FOUNDATION BY CENTRALIZING
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS SUPPORTING
HIS BUSINESS FUNCTIONS NOW
WE'RE READY TO BEGIN BUILDING
ON THOSE. FOX AND EXPANDING THE
ENTERPRISE CASE MANAGEMENT AND
MODELING SERVICES TO OUR AUDIT
MY LINE OF WORK. AND ACCOUNT
RECEIVABLE FUNCTIONS AS WELL AS
EXPANDED OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE
CHANNELS INCLUDING THE CHAPTER
FOLDER. EXTERNALLY KNOWN AS MY
YET TO BE. AS WELL AS ON THE
BUILDINGS. MOST LIKELY
ATTRIBUTE TABLE TO REPLACE
CRITICAL. SYSTEMS THAT ARE
PENDING END OF LIKE. IF THE
FUNDS ARE PENDING AND OF LIFE
AND WILL BE REPLACED DURING THE
EVENING ARCHIE PROJECT WILL
GENERATE OVER FOUR BILLION IN
ANNUAL FUNDING FOR THE GENERAL
FUND CURRENTLY. BUT THE BASIC
FINANCING. LETTERING COULD
RESOURCES ONLY FOR THE FIRST
YEAR OF THE PROJECT UNDOUBTEDLY
THE ONGOING OR LIMITED TERM
WITHIN THE BODY OF THE REQUEST.
THESE RESOURCES ARE REQUESTED
AND WILL ENSURE THAT. HAS THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF RESOURCES
FOR EXPECTS TOUGH FOR FIRST
YEAR OF THE PROJECT. AT THIS
TIME I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THERE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SEEN
NONE I DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS
EITHER QUESTIONS ANYBODY ELSE
ON THE PANEL THAT WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT A SERMON. THIS IS BRIAN
WEATHERFORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND I JUST WANTED TO- BRIEFLY
NOTE THAT OUR COMMENTS ARE-
INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA- GIVEN
YOU KNOW THE SIZE AND- YOU KNOW
CRITICALITY OF THIS- THIS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PROJECT
WORK- YOU KNOW MONITORING IT
AND- YOU KNOW DID HAVE SOME
COMMENTS ON- STAFFING AND THE-
THE- THE PAYMENTS. THEY ARE.
THE COMPENSATION FOR BETTER
COMPENSATION MODEL- SO IF YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE COMMENTS IN THE
AGENDA- I'M AVAILABLE TO- TO
DISCUSS THIS. THANK YOU MISTER
WEATHERFORD LET'S HEAR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE PLEASE. A
THIRD SENTENCE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE JUST WANT TO
MENTION TODAY THAT WE SUPPORT
THE FTP IS REQUEST. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE TO DO A VOTE ON THIS
BUT WE ARE MISSING. ONE MEMBER
CAN WE RETURN TO IT OKAY WELL
WHICH WILL RETURN TO THIS-
ISSUE ITEM UNTIL WE HAVE A FULL
QUORUM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON ACCIONES
FAMILY MEMBERS MY NAME IS TOO
LONG WHAT THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THE
PROPOSAL WITH YOU TODAY OUR
SECOND SPRING FINANCED LETTER
REQUESTING INCREASE THE
SPENDING AUTHORITY A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SEVEN
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WORTH OF CLEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. FOR THE ASSET
FORFEITURE ACCOUNTS. CBS
CRIMINAL THAT THE BUREAU WHEN
THESE FUNDS FOR CAUSES. WITH
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND
EQUIPMENT. TO BE IS A
TRANSCRIPT OF THE PLAY ON
SEVERAL FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
TASK FORCE TO INVESTIGATE
SUSPECTED REFUND FRAUD. FAILURE
TO FILE TAX RETURNS AT THE
FOLLOWING A FALSE OR FRAUDULENT
TAX RETURNS. THIS PROGRAM HELPS
TO REDUCE THE TAX GAP BY
HELPING BRING INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESS ENTITIES INVOLVED IN
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY INTO
COMPLIANCE CALIFORNIA'S TAX
LAWS. I'M. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT LET'S HEAR FROM
THE L. L. HI THIS IS BRIAN WITH
AFFORD WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THIS REQUEST WE
DO KNOW THAT HAVE TO BE
DEVELOPED A MULTI YEAR
EXPENDITURE PLAN TO SPEND ON
THE BALANCE- IN ITS ASSET
FORFEITURE ACCOUNT AND THIS
APPEARS TO BE A SUSTAINABLE
PLAN AND APPEARS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE ALLOWABLE
USES. OF THESE FUNDS. THANK YOU
LETTER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THIRTY SEVEN PARKER
FINANCE AGAIN WE- SUPPORT THIS
REQUEST. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENOL ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. THIS ALSO REQUIRES A
VOTE BUT WE WILL COME BACK TO
THAT AS WELL. LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOR INCREASED
LITIGATION COSTS. I THINK IT
THANK YOU OUR FINAL PROPOSAL IS
FOR AUGMENTATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO F. TWO BEATS
LITIGATION PROJECT WITH THE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL'S OFFICE FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IN ORDER TO DEFEND AGAINST
TAX REFORM LAWSUIT. OVER THE
PAST TEN YEARS SB HAS CONTINUED
TO SEE INCREASED LITIGATION
EFFORTS WITH VERY COMPLEX TAX
MATTERS IS AUGMENTATION ENSURES
THAT WE CAN ADEQUATELY PROTECT
THE STATE'S WHICH IN THIS CASE
THAT. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THIS
ONE. THANK YOU LET'S HEAR FROM
THE L. A. L. WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH A SEPARATE
REQUEST. THANK YOU DON'T
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PATTERSON
STRUGGLED FINDING SKIN WE ALSO
SUPPORT THIS REQUEST. GREAT
THANK YOU ANY COMMENT COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
OKAY SEEING NONE AT THIS-
REQUIRES- EMOTIONS ARE MOTION.
THANK ROLL CALL PLEASE CARILLO
HI CHIU COOPER- ACT LACKING
THIS AREA HI. THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO OUR TWO
PREVIOUS. ISSUES THAT NEEDED A
VOTE A LET'S GO TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO ENTERPRISE DATA TO REVENUE
PROJECT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE
THIS BUDGET TO THE RESOURCES
AND JANUARY BUDGET AND THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTERS ARE
MOTION. THE SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE CARILLO HI CHIU COOPER
BUT LACKEY NAZARIAN. THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD TO THE
NEXT ONE THAT'S ISSUE THREE THE
ASSET FORFEITURE ACCOUNT
INCREASE OUR RECOMMENDATION IS
TO APPROVE THE SPRING FINANCE
LITTERIS BUDGET THAT'S OUR
MOTION. SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE
CARILLO HI CHIU COOPER I LAGGY
NAZARIAN. FIVE THANK YOU AND-
WE CAN NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE HOUSING LAW
ASSISTANCE LET'S BEGIN. I HATE
THAT MAKING COULD BE HERE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT I'M THE DIRECTOR
AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
HOUSING POLICY DIVISION AND
THAT IS PUTTING FORWARD THAT-
ED THE REQUESTED. FOR SIXTEEN
DIFFERENT WITH THAT. OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HOUSING THE BAND-
WITH- ACROSS WHAT- HOW THE LOTS.
AND WE AND WE'RE BUCKLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ASPECTS OF THIS WORK
AND I DIDN'T WANT TO AND TOUCH
ON THAT A BIT TODAY THAT- MUCH
OF WHAT WE AND MUCH OF WHAT WE
ARE DOING IN THE FINAL WORK AS
WE ARE- WE ARE. DOING THIS AND
ALREADY AN EXISTING CAPACITY
AND A TO BE AN EXPANSION OF
STAFFING REPORT THAT. IS WE ARE
FREQUENTLY IN CONTACT WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS THEY ARE
DEVELOPING THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTING
THOSE HOUSING ELEMENT AND
CARING FOR HELPING PLANNING
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES- WHAT
OFTEN ASK YOU TO GIVE GUIDANCE
ON- ON THOSE LAWS AND ALSO WE
DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS- THERE IS A GENERAL-
STATEWIDE COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
LAWS. AND THAT DOES START FROM
AND CLAIMING THAT BOTH THE FANS
AND I THINK I THINK- WE WOULD
CONTINUE THAT APPROACH HERE.
THANK YOU TO THE FACT THAT MORE
WITH THE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LET'S HEAR FOR THE L. A- PLEASE.
HELLO NOTED MORALIS THE LARGEST
ATALLAH OFFICE. WE ALSO HAVE
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL WHEN IT WAS
FIRST PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
IN JANUARY ABOUT HOW OLD THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT AND FORSMAN
ASPECTS WOULD BE BALANCED WE
REALLY APPRECIATE HEARING FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
INTENT REALLY IT'S JUST. EXPAND
CAPACITY ESSENTIALLY HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL CONCERN ST STE. THE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU. THANK
RESTAURANTS LET'S FROM THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS DANA
CRUZ DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I JUST A COMMENT TO
BE CLEAR THE ENFORCEMENT THAT
IS AUTHORIZED UNDER THIS B. C.
P. IS ONLY THE ENFORCEMENT THAT
HAS BEEN AUTHORIZED BY
LEGISLATION THAT HAS BEEN
PASSED H. C. D. IS NOT PLANNING
ON YOU ENFORCEMENT POLICIES
THROUGH THIS BCP. THAT ACCURATE.
BACK ACTIVE THIS IS A DIFFERENT
EXISTING AUTHORITY- THE ONLY
THE FACT AND CAPACITY THINK
ABOUT THAT FIFTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S SUM THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE S.
BUDGET THAT'S OUR MOTION. FROM
THEIR SECOND BROKE UP PLEASE
THREEA HI CHIU COOPER FIVE
LACKEY WAS AREA I. THANK YOU.
LET'S MOVE FORWARD TO A ISSUE
NUMBER SIX FISCAL I'M SORRY
SPRING FISCAL LETTERS THIS IS
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE
LET'S BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TAMERA
MARCH AND I'M THAT CALIFORNIA
STATE ARCHIVIST AND DIVISION
CHIEF OF THE ARCHIVES DIVISION.
AT THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE I WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU THIS
AFTERNOON. AND I'M HERE TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH INFORMATION ON
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
OF ARCHIVES DIVISION AND THAT
CREATING ACCESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM. OUR RECORDS
PROPOSAL. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ARCHIVES DIVISION. AT COLLECT
PROTECT AND PROVIDE ACCESS TO
THE HISTORICAL RECORDS MULTI
BRAND WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT INCLUDING A
STATE LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS
SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES.
DOCUMENTING. CALIFORNIA'S RICH
AND DIVERSE HISTORY. I
CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF STATE
PARK ITS DIVISION HAS BEEN A
CRITICAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNMENT PRESERVING THE
HISTORY OF ITS PEOPLE FOR OVER
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE
YEARS. RECORDS IN OUR
COLLECTION RANGE IN DATE FROM
PRE STATEHOOD WHICH IS PRIOR TO
EIGHTEEN FIFTY TO THOSE CREATED
JUST LAST WEEK. EACH YEAR THE
OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF STATE
ARCHIVES DIVISION AT THE
THOUSANDS OF CUSTOMERS
REQUIRED. INFORMATION FROM THE
STATE OUR EYES FOR TIME
SENSITIVE. TIMES OF THE
LEGISLATIVE LEGAL BUSINESS AND-
RESEARCH PURPOSES. SOME OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN INCREASING
URGENCY DUE TO THE GLOBAL
HEALTH CRISIS SAYS. BUT THAT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
RECORDS OUR COLLECTION THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ARCHIVES
THAT'S PROBABLY. ONE OF THE
LARGEST STATE ARCHIVES
COLLECTIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES AND ALL US TERRITORIES.
RECORDS IN THE COLLECTION ARE
IN A BRIGHT IDEA FORMATS
INCLUDING DOCUMENTS MAPS
PHOTOGRAPHS AUDIO VISUAL
MATERIALS AN ARTIFACT. BUT THE
MAJORITY ARE PAPER AND LESS
THAN 1% OF THE COLLECTION
DIGITIZED AND AVAILABLE ONLINE
DUE TO LIMITED RESOURCES OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. THAT'S WHAT MAKES
IT CHALLENGING FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO BE RECORDS UNLESS
THEY'RE ABLE TO TRAVEL IN
PERSON TO OUR LOCATION
SACRAMENTO. ARE ABLE TO
PURCHASE COPIES THEIR STATE
YEAH AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THIS HAS BECOME MORE
CHALLENGING DUE TO THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC. AS MANY ARE
EXPERIENCING ECONOMIC HARDSHIP.
THIS PROPOSAL THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE GENERAL FUND.
AUGMENTATION OF THREE MILLION
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND ONE POINT SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND JUST CLEAR TWENTY
TWO TO TWENTY THREE AND- AT AND
ON GOING AND THREE EXHIBITIONS
AUTOMATE KEEPER BASED
PROPERTIES AND SUPPORT INCREASE
ON MY AND CON. CONTACT WITH
ACCESS TO THE STATE TO START
PUBLIC RECORDS AND DATA HUB IN
THE STATE ARCHIVES IN RESPONSE
TO THE ONGOING COMPANY EIGHTEEN
PANDEMIC. CANNOT ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE THANKS
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU THANK. YOU MISS MARTIN
LET'S HEAR FROM THE L. L. GOOD
AFTERNOON NICK SCHROEDER WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. BOB THE ONLY COMMENT I
WILL ADD TO THIS IS THAT OUR
OFFICE DID TO REPORT A FEW
YEARS AGO. LOOKING AT THE STATE
ARCHIVES AND AT THAT TIME. WE
DID IDENTIFY THAT THERE IS SUCH
THEIR PHYSICAL STORAGE SPACE
WAS DIMINISHING AND DIMINISHING
RATHER QUICKLY AND AT THE TIME
WE PROJECTED. BUT THEY MIGHT
RUN OUT OF SPACE BY BECAUSE THE
TWENTY THIRTIES. AND THIS- THIS
PROPOSAL OF INCREASING
DIGITIZATION OF RECORDS WOULD
SLOW THAT- DIMINISHING OF THEIR
PHYSICAL SPACE AND SO COULD
PROLONG THE AMOUNT OF TIME FOR
THE ACTION NEED MORE SPACE.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TOMORROW JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOTHING TO
ADD THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE. I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
OF FOR MISS MARTIN WHY WERE
THESE REQUEST NOT INCLUDED IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET. IT HISTORIC
NATURE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE HAVE LIMITED
STAFF RESOURCES AT THE TIME.
THE BASED ON WORKLOAD AND
AVAILABILITY WE WERE ADVISED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
PARTNER TECHNOLOGY. BEFOREIT
THAT SPRING FINANCE LETTER
PROCESS AND ALLOW FOR TIME
AFTER THE ELECTION TO PROPERLY
DOCUMENT AND COMPLETE THE
REQUIRED ITEMS FOR THE PROJECT
APPROVAL HOW PROCESS LIFE CYCLE
EFFECTIVELY. AND MISS MARTIN
ARE THESE ARE THE THREE NEW
POSITIONS IN THE ARCHIVE
SUFFICIENT TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIANS ASKING FOR.
HISTORIC RECORDS DIGITALLY. AT
YES FOR THE THREE POSITIONS
OUTLINED IN THIS PROPOSAL ARE
IDENTIFIED AS CRITICAL
POSITIONS FOR THE PROJECT. THE
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
COORDINATING THE AUTOMATION OF
PAPER BASED PROCESS EASIER FOR
IMPLEMENTATION AND DIGITIZATION
OF PAPER BASESTAR PUBLIC
RECORDS. AND JUST AT SO YOU'RE
AWARE AT THE POSITIONS THAT
INCLUDE ONE ASSOCIATE
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM ANALYST
ONE ARTIST YOU. AND WHEN IT
SPECIALISTS ONE. AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT BY AUTOMATING
THE- PROCESS THESE EXISTING
STAFF WILL BE IN THE ROCHESTER
FOR DIGITIZATION EFFORT INTO
PRODUCTS ONLINE ACCESSIBILITY
TO STARKEL RECORDS. AND SAY OUR
X. SERVICES AND FOLLOWING
IMPLEMENTATION WE WILL
DETERMINE IF THERE IS A NEED TO
COME BACK TO REQUEST ADDITIONAL
RESOURCE THAT IS A GREAT
CUSTOMER SERVICE IMPROVEMENTS
STAND OR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO DIGITIZE THE CONTENT OF THE
ARCHIVES WHICH MAY PROVIDE
FURTHER COST AVOIDANCE. SAVINGS
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU IN ONE
FINAL. DOES THE ANTICIPATE NEW
INITIATIVE IN THE NEAR FUTURE
FOR THE MUSIC. UNDERSECRETARY
OF ANALYZING AND EVALUATING THE
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES THAT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO COMING-BACK IN THE FUTURE BUT MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE AN IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES RELATED TO THE
SECRETARY OF. STATE'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWERS WITH
MARTIN MUCH APPRECIATED. THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTERS ARE
MOTION. MODE FIVE MISTER COOPER
SECOND BY MR ASSYRIAN I
REALIZED THAT I WAS NOT SAYING
THAT EARLIER MY APOLOGIES UP
ROLL CALL PLEASE CARILLO I.
CHIU COOPER- LACKEY THIS AREA.
THANK YOU. AND NOW WE GO TO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN SPECIAL
ELECTION AND THANKS TO THE
PANEL WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN SPECIAL
ELECTION COSTS LET'S BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
GENERALLY NINETY FOR THE
ELECTIONS DIVISION FOR THE
SECRETARY EIGHT BOXES. THE
RESPECTFULLY CONCORD WITH ITS
BRING FINANCE LETTER TO GET AN
ADDITIONAL ELECTION RESOURCES
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE IS
REQUESTING. A GENERAL FUND ON
ONE ONE MOMENT RENOWNED OF ONE
ONE POINT ONE MOMENT PLEASE
MISS LANE BECAUSE THE PROFESSOR.
WITH THE PRINTER PROPOSAL. SHE
SHE SHE'S TALKING MANY. SIX
SEVEN. ALL RIGHT SHE SEVENTY
SECOND EDITION SIX. METHYLENE
WE ARE ON THE ISSUE SEVEN. OKAY
FOR THE MOMENT FOR WITH ISSUE
SEVEN SORRY MA'AM THAT'S OKAY
THANK YOU- THANK YOU TO OUR
OKAY ARE A GREAT OTHER
CONSULTANTS FOR CATCHING THAT.
THANK YOU IF I WERE TO GET
GOING THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT. AND SO I BELIEVE YOU HAD
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
POTENTIAL RECALL. YES OKAY- SO
IF I RECALL YOUR QUESTIONS
CORRECTLY YOU HAD A QUESTION
ABOUT- WHY- THE COSTS WOULD BE
SO HIGH THAT HAVE BEEN PREVIOUS
ELECTIONS WELL FOR THE RECALL
ELECTION I COULD PAY FOR THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE I
DO KNOW WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE COUNTY CLERK'S
ELECTION OFFICIALS ASSOCIATION
ON THE FOLLOWING ALSO BUT WE
ARE NOT IN THE STAGE YET- TO
DETERMINE ANY COSTS FOR THE
POTENTIAL SPECIAL ELECTION. I
WANT TO GET TO THAT PAGE AFTER
WERE DONE WITH THEIR SIGNATURE
RECALL DAYS WE CAN WORK WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE WILL
TOPPLE THE WORK WITH THE COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS ARE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
DETERMINE THOSE ANTICIPATED
COSTS SO WE HAVE NOT DONE THAT-
THAT EVALUATION. YET BUT WE
WILL DO THAT IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
THANK YOU MESCALINE WHAT WE
HEAR FROM MISS DONNA JOHNSTON.
CENTER CAMPUS CENTER COUNTY
CLERK IN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF CLERKS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
ON THE SPECIAL ELECTION COSTS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON I AM DONNA
JOHNSTON SUTTER COUNTY REGISTER
VOTERS CURRENT PRESIDENT OF.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLARKSON ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS CA CEO.
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
SESSION AND GIVING OUR
ASSOCIATION THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS ELECTION COSTS WITH
YOU. SEE A SENIOR WAS BEEN
COLLECTING PRIMARY AND GENERAL
ELECTION COST DATA BACK TO THE
PRIMARY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE. IT'S A VOLUNTARY STUDY
AND THEREFORE NOT ALL COUNTIES
PROVIDE DATA THE FIRST PRIMARY
OF TWENTY THOUSAND TO TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE HAD AN
AVERAGE COST OF SEVEN DOLLARS
PER VOTER. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TRI PRIOR TO THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY ELECTION AVERAGE COSTS
FOR. UP TO TWELVE DOLLARS PER
VOTER. THE COST FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
ROSE TO AN AVERAGE OF EIGHTEEN
DOLLARS PER VOTER FROM THE
THIRTY NINE COUNTIES WHO
RESPONDED TO OUR SURVEY SO FAR.
WE CONTINUE AT THE STATE TO
COLLECT DATA FROM COUNTIES HAD
NOT RESPONDED. TAKING THE
EIGHTEEN DOLLAR PER VOTER.
NUMBER AND MULTIPLYING IT TO
THE NUMBER OF REGISTERED VOTERS
IN THE STATE FOR THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION THE
RESULT IS JUST UNDER FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION. MORE
PRECISELY- THREE HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN MILLION. THE SIX DOLLAR
PER VOTER COST INCREASE. JUST
FROM MARCH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY WERE
LARGELY RESULT OF MANDATES.
THESE INCLUDED COVERT RELATED
ITEMS SUCH AS BP ABOVE WHAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE SO
GRACIOUSLY PROVIDED. EAST COAST
WHICH FOR A ALL MAIL BALLOT
ELECTION WHICH INCLUDED BOTH
OUTGOING AND INCOMING BALLOTS
IN PERSON VOTING OPPORTUNITIES
FOLLOWING COKE PRODUCTS.
PROTOCOLS INCREASED NUMBER OF
REQUIRED BALLOT DROP BOXES
INCREASED EARLY VOTING
OPPORTUNITIES ADDING
INTELLIGENT MAIL BARCODES TO
ENVELOPES TO WORK WITHOUT
TRACKING SYSTEMS AND INCREASED
PROMOTED SOCIAL VOTING BY MAIL
VOTING OPPORTUNITIES. BLOOD
REGISTRATION DURING THIS TIME
ALSO INCREASED ONE POINT THREE
MILLION FROM THE PRIMARY
ELECTION. IF THE SAME
CONDITIONS EXIST FOR THE
POTENTIAL RECALL THAT DID IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
EXPECTED COST TO COUNTIES COULD
BE UP TO THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. I HAVE TO SAY
THAT CCO IS ENCOURAGED BY THE
EARLY DIALOGUE. TO HOPEFULLY
HELP RELIEVE THE COST OF OUR
COUNTIES TO CONDUCT THE
POTENTIAL RECALL ELECTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
JOHNSTON IS MR JOE WHITE ON THE
LINE. I AM A LOT. OKAY LET'S
THE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
FROM EITHER THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE. IF THE
GENERATED ELECTED DIVISION
AGAIN SO WE WILL WORK
COOPERATIVELY OF COURSES DONNA
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO GO THROUGH ALL OF THOSE
NUMBERS AS WE GET TO THAT PAGE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
ON GETTING DOWN TO THE BOTTOM
OF ALL OF THE COSTS FOR THE
ELECTION. I WOULD HAVE TO AGREE
WITH DONNA THE- ALEXION COSTS
HAVE CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY OVER
THE YEARS DUE TO ALL OF THE NEW
LEGISLATION THAT HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE ON MAKING SURE THAT
THE COUNTIES ARE FUNDED. FOR
THE ELECTION THAT MAY NEED TO
BE CALLED. THANK YOU- IS THERE
SOMEONE FROM THE ALEJO'S OFFICE.
HEY NICK SCHROEDER FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEEN SAID SO FAR IN TERMS OF
THE FACT THAT ELECTION BECAUSE
SEVEN INCREASING OVER TIME IT'S
LARGELY DUE BECAUSE HOW PEOPLE
VOTE HAS CHANGED A LOT. OVER
TIME AS WELL AS THE- MANDATES
THAT BEEN ESTABLISHED THE ONE
THING THAT I WOULD ADD IS THAT
THE ASSOCIATION'S ESTIMATES
WERE BASED ON THAT NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION AND SO.
IT REALLY DEPENDS ON THE EXTENT
TO WHICH A RECALL ELECTION
WOULD HAVE A SIMILAR SITUATION
ADDS THAT NOVEMBER RECALL
NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER IT'S COSTS
ACTUALLY REFLECTED THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION SO I REALLY JUST DON'T
KNOW WHAT A RECALL ELECTION
MIGHT LOOK LIKE IT DEPENDS ON
THE LENGTH OF THE BALLOT. IT
DEPENDS ON WHAT KIND OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS ARE IN EFFECT AT
THE TIME OR THAT THE REGISTERS
PREPARE FOR- IN ADVANCE FOR
THAT SO REQUIRING PP OR LARGER
FACILITIES- FOR IN PERSON
VOTING OR FOR EARLY VOTING- AND
THE LAST THING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD IS. THAT AS THE
LEGISLATURE MOVES FORWARD AND
CONSIDERING WHAT IF ANY- STATE
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED- TO ASSIST
COUNTIES. IN ANY RECALL
ELECTION WOULD BE TO EXPLORE TO
WHAT EXTENT OF THE STATE'S
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE TO
PAY FOR THE COVETED RELATED
EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
ELECTION- WE AS END OF THE
STATE RECEIVE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY THROUGH THE A.
R. P. AND THE STATE HAS A
FAIRLY WIDE DISCRETION HOW TO
USE THAT MONEY THAT BEING SAID.
WE'RE WAITING FROM- U. S.
TREASURY TO GET THE ACTUAL
SPECIFICS OF HOW THE FUNDS CAN
BE USED- IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE
FUNDS COULD BE USED TO OFFSET
AT LEAST A PORTION OF THE COSTS
WHATEVER THEY END UP BEING- FOR
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO JUST
WANNA. MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S ON
THE RADAR FOR THE LEGISLATURE-
MOVING. FOR THANK YOU IS THERE
SOMEONE FORM- MISS JOHNSON
DEPARTED FINANCE. THANK YOU TO
MARK JOHNSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE AS WELL THAT
IT IS A VERY EARLY IN THE
PROCESS TO HAVE ESTIMATED COSTS
AT THIS TIME BUT FINANCE IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH- THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE. TO
ESTIMATE- TO COME UP WITH THAT
THAT INFORMATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS AND ALSO DO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ISSUE.
HELLO I HAVE A COUNTIES BEGAN
PLANNING HOW TO ABSORB THE
ADDITIONAL COST MISTER JOHNSTON.
CANDIES ARE PREPARING TO GO TO
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO ASK
FOR THE COSTS POTENTIAL COST
FOR THE ELECTIONS WHEN THEY ARE
AT THIS POINT IN TIME GATHERING
DATA TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN GIVE AN ACCURATE.
REFLECTION OF WHAT THOSE COSTS
ARE IT'S GOING TO BE UP TO EACH
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
THINK THIS IS YOUR HELL TO FUND
THE SELECTION. SOME HARD
DECISIONS WE HAVE TO BE MADE.
UHHUH AND HERE'S THE HERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A HISTORICAL
QUESTION BUT HOW MUCH DID THE
TWO THOUSAND THREE WE CALL COST
AND WHO PAID FOR THOSE COSTS.
SERVICES DAN ARRANGEMENT
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE NOW
I WOULD LIKE. THAT THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE ALEXION WHATNOT
CONDUCTED AS AN ALL MAIL BALLOT
ELECTION. I THINK WHAT THE
ALIENS OFFICE HAS BOOTED YOU
KNOW ACTION LOG AND CHANGE
SIGNIFICANTLY. SPENT THEIR TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE ELECTION-
ALSO THAT WE HAVE COSTS LIKE
IT'S BECAUSE THE CUTS RELIGIOUS
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE.
FOR THE ACT THE TWO THOUSAND
THREE RECALL ELECTION. THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE DID
PUT IN A BUDGET DEFICIENCY AT
THE END OF AN NTICIPATED COSTS
OF. THE STATE VOTER INFORMATION
GUIDE ON SUCH AS THE CONDENSED
TIME FRAME TO PRINT AND MAIL.
TRANSFORMATION GUIDE WE ARE
UNAWARE THAT THE STATE OF
REIMBURSED THE COUNTY FOR THE
CONDUCT OF THE TWO THOUSAND
THREE OR ELECTION.
UNFORTUNATELY BY SEVERAL OF US
FOLKS HERE WERE NOT CONDUCTING
ELECTIONS IN. TWO THOUSAND
THREE SO WE DO NOT HAVE THOSE
RECORDS INTO. WHERE WHAT THE
RECORD BECAUSE- WHERE OR THEY
ARE I KNOW. A MAN I DO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO.
DETERMINE THE COST THAT WERE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND THREE AND WE
WILL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT QUESTION I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY I KNOW WE'VE WE'VE ALREADY
ADDRESSED THIS AND I DON'T WANT
TO. BELABOR THE FACT BUT WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT LEAD CURRENT OF
POTENTIAL RECALL WOULD BE
CONDUCTED AT OF WITH EVERY
REGARDING A VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
WHICH WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE ANY ELECTION CALL AND
ALSO THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT
MODEL OF OPENING EARLY VOTING
SITES AT THE L. A. YOU KNOW THE
CAPTAIN AND THE NUMBER OF DAYS
HAVE SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASE.
SO I DO BELIEVE WE WOULD BE
COMPARING APPLES AND ORANGES
EXACTLY THAT AT ELECTION WAS
CONDUCTED MANY MANY YEARS AGO
AND I THOUGHT I WA WITH
EIGHTEEN AKSAKOV HAVE GONE.
SIGNIFICANTLY AT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS I THINK THE ONE
HOUR LECTURE THAT WE COULD LOOK
TO ALTHOUGH IT WOULD DEFINITELY
NOT BE A COMPARISON WOULD BE
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND NEWMAN
RECALL ACTION THIS ELECTION WAS
CONDUCTED ON THESE CURRENT- WE
CONTACT YOU. HOWEVER THIS
ELECTION WAS ONLY CONDUCTED AND
WITH THREE COUNTY LOS ANGELES
ORANGE AND SAMPOERNA DINO- IF
THEIR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WORKED WITH THESE THREE
COUNTIES TO ESTIMATE THAT A
STANDALONE ELECTION WOULD COST
ABOUT TWO POINT SIX MILLION
VOTERS IN MARCH TWO POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS- I NEED TO LOOK
AT HOW MANY VOTERS THAT
ENTAILED BUT- JUST BELOW THAT
OF THE- SENATE- COMMITTEE IS
AWARE. THAT THIS ELECTION WAS
CONSOLIDATED WITH THE JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PRIMARY
ELECTION SO THE ESTIMATED COST
WOULD CLOSER. TO NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
AM- THE INFORMATION THAT IT'S
NOT THE SAME. I'D SAY LIKE TO
KNOW HOW MUCH IT COST WHAT IS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND THREE RECALL OF A
GOVERNOR AND THIS POTENTIAL
RECALL NOW ESPECIALLY IF.
ESPECIALLY IF THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
LAWS HAVE CHANGED IN. MORE
CALIFORNIANS ARE VOTING BY MAIL
AND- WE'RE NOT PROVIDING THEM
NO NEED TO PUT A STAMP ON
RETURNING YOUR BALLOT. HOWEVER
I WOULD STILL LIKE TO KNOW ONE
WHERE THE WHERE IS THE
INFORMATION FOR WHAT IT COSTS
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE AND WHAT
WOULD IT BE COMPARING IT. WHAT
WOULD BE THE COMPARISON NOW. IN
TERMS OF ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. DO YOU HAVE AN IDEA
AS TO WHEN YOU MAY KNOW THE
COST. PLEASE REPLY COULD COME
BUT I DID NOT HAVE THE- ACTUAL
INFORMATION I CAN PROVIDE YOU
WITH PROXIMATE LI FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AGAIN I WOULD NEED TO
LOOK BACK AT THE NUMBER OF
REGISTERED VOTERS THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE- WENT LIVE
VOTING BY MAIL AND- WHAT THE
DIFFERENT COMPARISON WOULD BE
FINE ALL MAIL BALLOT ELECTION
SO WELL IT IS THE ONLY ABOUT
ELECTIONS THOSE GIFT
CERTIFICATE. ACCESS TO ALL
VOTERS IT DOES HAVE A DIFFERENT
CUSTOMER IN THE LECTION
ILLINOIS I KEEP COMING BACK TO
THAT BUT ACTUALLY INCREASE. THE
ABILITY FOR VOTERS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO LOADING AND THE
ABILITY TO CHOOSE HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO VOTE I THINK THAT DOES
CREATE A COST. TO THE STATE AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT THEY
CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS HAVE BEEN
RUN VERY SUCCESSFULLY OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS I WOULD SAY
THAT THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION WAS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST- WELL RUN AND SECURE
ELECTIONS THAT WE'VE HAD IN
SEVERAL SEVERAL YEARS. I WITH
THAT IT WAS RUN UNDER THESE
SPECIFIC NEW ALONG WITH A
COUPLE OF YOU KNOW ALLOWING ALL
BOATERS IN CALIFORNIA TO VOTE
BY MAIL HOW THE EARLY VOTING
OPTIONS AND HAVE DROP BOXES.
AND OVERALL OPTIONS ON HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE. YOU HAVE
BEEN BUTCHERED. THANK YOU APRIL
THAT BUT THE END OF MY QUESTION.
DO YOU KNOW. WHEN DO THINK YOU
WILL KNOW. THE APPROXIMATE.
WE'VE GOT THE APARTMENT COMPLEX
I HAVE IN ANY OF MY EXPERIENCE
WE WILL WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION NOT BE
DETERMINANT. OKAY SO RIGHT NOW
DO YOU ACT YOU DON'T HAVE A
POTENTIAL DATE AS TO WHEN YOU
MIGHT KNOW. BUT FOR MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND. YES MA'AM I
UNDERSTAND BUT NOT AT THIS TIME
BUT I WILL DEFINITELY GET BACK
WITH YOU IN THE NEW YEAR YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF. IF AND IF WE
CAN DETERMINE FACTUAL CROFT AND
WHAT WOULD WHAT WOULD IN FACT
REIMBURSED TO THE COUNTY. ONE
FINAL QUESTION THANK YOU FOR
THAT IS IF THE STATE. WHICH
ALREADY PROVIDES FUNDING TO
COUNTIES FOR ELECTIONS WERE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
FOR THE SPECIAL RECALL. WHAT
WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE SHARE
OF COST. I DO THINK THIS IS A
BIT PREMATURE FOR THAT WE STILL
NEED TO WORK WITH ATTORNEYS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
DETERMINE WHAT COSTS WOULD BE-
I THINK THAT LEN AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE COULD
ADDRESS THE STUDENTS WHETHER
THE NEEDY. BUT THE STATE
MANDATES HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED
FOR SEVERAL YEARS SO I DO KNOW
THAT WHILE COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS WENT THOSE. CROPS ARE
NO LONGER ACTIVE SPENDING THEY
MAY BE ABLE TO COME BACK TO THE
STATE TO. SECURE THOSE FINES
BUT AS OF NOW WE COUNTY ELECTED
OFFICIALS HAVE NOT BEEN
REIMBURSED FOR COUNTY ELECT FOR
STATEWIDE ELECTION. IN THEIR
COUNTIES FOR SEVERAL YEARS. GOT
IT THANK YOU FOR THAT. NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. OKAY WE ARE GOING TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THIS PANEL. WE ARE
MOVING ON TO. CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER. THE MANAGED CARE AND
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS MONEY
IT'S JUST AN HOUR AND THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR FISCAL
POLICY ADMINISTRATION OF THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY-
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY 28%
OUR SPRING FINANCE LETTER TO
YOU AS YOU MAY RECALL EARLIER
THIS YEAR WE ASK CAME IN FRONT
OF THIS COMMITTEE TO DISCUSS
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A STATE
WIDE CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER
POSITION WITHIN OUR AGENCY-
UPON. AND HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION WITH THIS WITH WAS A
LOT OF COMMERCE AND I'M ROBUST
AND DISCUSSION REGARDING JUST
RESOURCES AND POTENTIAL NEEDS
TO SUPPORT THE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER TO ENSURE THAT MISSION
THAT WE WANT THAT TYPICALLY
OFFICER TO FULFILL CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED AS A RESULT OF
THAT CONVERSATION DURING THIS
HEARING- WE WENT BACK AND
ANALYZE THE WORK THAT WAS TO BE
DONE IF WE- COME FORWARD WITH
AN ADDITIONAL RESOURCE REQUEST
TO SUPPORT THE STATE. THE
PROPOSED A WHITE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER POSITION THAT REQUEST
IS FOR TO POSITIONS AND TWO
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND. THESE WILL BE
CONDITIONS THAT WILL HELP TO.
TRACK DELIVERABLES ANALYZE DATA
AND- MANAGE PROJECTS STATEWIDE
FEEDBACK WE OFFICER WOULD BE
PERFORMING AS PART OF THEIR
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES-
WITH THAT ORIGINAL PROPOSAL AND
THERE WAS ALSO SO SHE COULD
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO ESTABLISH
DISAGREEMENTS AND POSITION.
WITHIN OUR AGENCY- WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND WE ARE.
WILLING TO HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ON THAT TRAILER
BILL AS IT IS ADOPTED AND SPENT
HER SUGGESTED TO BE A DOCTOR'S
PLACE WHERE TRAILER BILL. WENT
BACK WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT OUR
REFINANCE ALSO OUR REGION ALSO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUST
HOWARD- HELLO. PRIME MINISTER
LEGISLATE ANALYST OFFICE WE
HAVE NO WITH THIS PURPOSE. THE
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WHAT
I WANTED OF THE FINANCE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS WOULD HAVE NO
CALL ACOSTA. THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS LIKE FROM COMMITTEE.
MISTER COOPER. MADAM CHAIR-
WHAT'S LISTINGS GIVE ME WHAT'S
THE BIG ROLE THE CHIEF THAT WE
OFFER PLAYED A DEFINING AND
CLOSING GAPS IN RACIAL AND
GENDER PAY EQUITY IN THE STATE
WORKFORCE. YES THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTIONS BUT ONE OF THE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITIES WILL
BE FOR THE CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER
POSITION BE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH OUR HR AND WHICH IS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT THAT REPORTS ARE
AGENCY THEY ARE ONE OF THE
CONTROL AGENCY DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN THE STATE. AND THEY'LL
BE WORKING. CORRECTLY WITH THEM
AND COLLECTING THE NECESSARY
DATA FOR US TO ANALYZE AND
REVIEW- TO. HELP CLOSE. ANY
EQUITY GAPS AND THAT WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT ANNOUNCED. IS
THERE A TIMELINE FOR DEFINING
AND CREATING A PLAN TO ADDRESS
THE- YEP. YES THANK THANKS FOR
THAT FOLLOW UP QUESTION THE
GOAL IS TO BEGIN THAT WORK
IMMEDIATELY UPON HIRING THAT
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER WHAT THEY
WILL NEED TO DO IS THEN PUT
FORWARD A PLAN INCLUDING A
TIMELINE FOR IT AND- HOUSE
EXCEPT TO SLEEP LAST NIGHT GAPS
SO THAT WILL BE ONE OF THE
FIRST TASK WILL BE CONDUCTED.
ONCE WE BRING THIS POSITION ON
BOARD WHICH WE HOPE TO DO
MASSIVE JULY ONE IN FACT WE ARE
ALREADY. BEGINNING THAT PROCESS.
OF TRYING TO. IN ADVANCE OF. WE
WILL. FEELERS THE POSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER AT
QUESTIONS HAS THE AGENCY SEEN
SB SEVENTEEN AND IF SO HOW
WOULD THIS PROPOSAL A CHANGE OF
SB SEVENTEEN WAS ADOPTED. YES
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I IN
FACT WE HAVE SEEN THE SEVENTEEN
BUT ONLY JUST RECENTLY AT ALL A
WEEK AND A HALF AGO IT KIND OF
CAME ACROSS OUR AGENCIES FIVE
DESK FOR A REVIEW. WE ARE
CURRENTLY ANALYZING SB
SEVENTEEN WHICH I BELIEVE IS
FROM SENATOR PAN- AND
IDENTIFYING WHAT THE POTENTIAL
COSTS ASSOCIATED ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS FOR THAT PROPOSAL IS AND
HOW IT WOULD IMPACT WHAT WE
WERE PLANNING TO DO WITH. THIS
POSITION. WE VERY CONFIDENT
REGARDLESS OF. WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THAT POSITION THAT THE
POSITIONS THAT WE ARE ASKING
THE WORK- WITHIN THE STATE AND-
SB SEVENTEEN APPEARS TO
ESTABLISH. A AT MANDATE MONTHS
ALL STATE AGENCIES TO PERFORM
CERTAIN FUNCTIONS RELATED TO
EQUITY INCLUSION AND- A STRONG
LIKELIHOOD THAT IF SOMETHING
LIKE THAT WORK SHE ALTERNATELY
BE APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
THAT ALL STATE AGENCIES WHEN
KERR SOMEWHERE COSTS- I THINK
WHAT WE'RE HOPING IS THROUGH
OUR PROPOSAL. THAT WE WOULD
ULTIMATELY BE ABLE TO- DO SOME
OF THIS WORK AND LEVERAGE
EXISTING RESOURCES ARE
CURRENTLY ARE WITHOUT HAVING TO
MANDATE. POTENTIAL ACTIVITIES.
THAT MAY ATTRACT COSTS SO. WITH
THAT AND WE ARE TO HAVE A FULL
ANALYSIS OF SB SEVENTEEN IN THE
NEAR FUTURE AND OF COURSE I'LL
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE NORMAL.
REVIEW PROCESS HERE
ADMINISTRATION. BEFORE THAT
ANALYSIS TO BE RELEASED. THANK
YOU FOR THAT APPRECIATEDFINO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE
THIS BUDGET IT ADOPTS THE
SPRING FISCAL LETTER AND DOPPA
PLACEHOLDER FOR TRAILER BILL
ANGUAGE IS OUR MOTION. MOVED
BY MR COOPER'S ARE SECOND
SECOND. SECOND BY MR THERRIEN
ROLL CALL PLEASE CARILLO HI
CHIU COOPER. LACKEY ARE THIS
AREA. THANK YOU THAT MEASURES
OUT LET'S GO TO ISSUE NUMBER
NINE THANK YOU TO THE PANEL
MUCH APPRECIATED DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY DIGITAL
IDENTIFICATION LET'S BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS AMY TOM AND THE STATE
YOU'RE FOR INFORMATION OFFICER
AND ALSO DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY. I WAS
MY PLEASURE HERE TO- ADDRESS
YOU ALL ARE WITH A COLLEAGUE-
TWO COLLEAGUES OF MINE- WHO'S
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO
WITH THE- PROPOSAL WITH MORE
DETAILS AS I HAVE BEEN AWAY.
AND JOINING THE VACCINE- A
STRIKE TEAM SINCE JANUARY SO
WITH THAT- LET WHICH INTRODUCE-
I'M SO SORRY THE DOORBELL RANG.
WITHOUT I'D LET ME INTRODUCE
YOU TO ON THE NEW CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AND DEPUTY STATE CHAU-
TO THE PROMINENT TECHNOLOGY-
REST NICHOLS AS WELL AS OUR
NEW. CHIEF TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION OFFICER FOR THE
STATE- ARE BRICK CLOUT SO.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR KONG. I
AFTERNOON I'M RUSTIC I AM THE
NEW CHIEF DEPUTY AT CDT- THE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU YES FOR TWO POSITIONS
OVER TWO BUDGET YEARS ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FISCAL
YEARS TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ARE
THEY YEARS SPECIFICALLY. WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING IS A TWO YEAR
EFFORT TO PLAN AND DESIGN AND
DEPLOY A PILOT IMPLEMENTATION
FOR SYSTEM TO ELECTRONICALLY
AND VERIFY THE IDENTITY OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHEN THEY
ACCESS THE STATE'S DIGITAL
SERVICE THE PILOT WILL LOOK TO
PROVE THE CONCEPT IN THE
TECHNOLOGY COMPONENTS NECESSARY
TO MEET OUR- GOALS AND AT THE
END OF THE PILOT WE WOULD
PRESENT BACK TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
ARE OUTCOMES. IN A PROPOSAL FOR
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE ROADMAP
OF HOW TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
OVERALL THE PROPOSAL IS
INTENDED TO SOLVE THREE MAJOR
GOALS FOR THE STATE THE FIRST
TO IMPROVE THE USER EXPERIENCE
FOR THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
WHEN THEY ACCESS STATE SYSTEMS
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THOSE SYSTEMS
ARE BUILT AND MAINTAINED IN
DEPARTMENTS INDEPENDENTLY. THAT
LEVEL OF EITHER USER
AUTHENTICATION AND IDENTITY
MANAGEMENT IS DONE DEPARTMENT
BY DEPARTMENT WHICH LEADS TO
VERY DIFFERENT USER EXPERIENCE
AS YOU TRANSITION ACROSS
DIFFERENT. STATE SERVICES IN
THE STATE. SECOND WE LOOK TO
INCREASE BOTH. AND THE PRICE
PROTECTIONS ALL OF THE- OF
CALIFORNIA AGAIN BECAUSE THE
SYSTEMS ARE MAINTAINED ACROSS
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS.
RESIDENTS ARE ASKED TO PROVIDE
THE SAME INFORMATION OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND IT IS STORED IN
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS SO THAT IS
ACTUALLY LESS SECURE AND LESS
MANAGED THAN IT WAS AT ONE
UNIFIED AND CONSISTENT STRAIGHT
UP. AND FINALLY BY REDUCING
THAT REDUNDANCY OF HAVING
DEPARTMENTS BUILD THE SAME
SYSTEM THE SAME IDENTIFICATION
SYSTEMS OVER AND OVER AGAIN. WE
LOOK TO NOT ONLY IMPROVE THE
SERVICE BUT REDUCE THE
REDUNDANCY AND COST ACROSS THE
VARIOUS STATE DEPARTMENTS. WITH
THAT WE'RE HERE AND HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE BEHALF. THANK YOU
MISTER NICHOLS AND
CONGRATULATIONS. ON THE TOPIC.
OF DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M
SORRY LET'S GO FIRST TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
BRIAN IT'S GOOD LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
BUDGET REQUEST US PROPOSED-
WITHOUT PREJUDICE TO THE
PROPOSAL'S POLICY MERITS. A
FIRST FOR ANY STATE ENTITY TO
REQUEST FUNDING TO PLAN IT
PROJECTS TO RECEIVE EIGHTEEN
HOW PROCESS YET THE TEAM MUST
SUBMIT A STAGE ONE BUSINESS
ANALYSIS. THAT IS APPROVED BY
SEATS NEED TO THE LEGISLATURE
UPON REQUEST ADMINISTRATION HAS
INDICATED TO OUR OFFENSE THAT
pNOW DOCUMENTATION IS STILL
UNDER REVIEW BY CDT. WHICH
MEANS THE LEGISLATURE DOES NOT
HAVE THE INFORMATION IT. NEEDS
TO FULLY EVALUATE THE PROPOSAL.
THANK THE PROPOSAL TRIAL IN. IS
TO LIMITED AND WHATNOT
DEMONSTRATE HOW FOR EXAMPLE A
SINGLE DIFFERENCE ALIKE IN A
FIRE WHAT WORKS FOR MORE
COMPLEX SERVICES OR SERVICES
THAT REQUIRE A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF COORDINATION WITH
FEDERAL AND OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THIRD THE PROPOSAL
RAISES A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT PRIVACY AND SECURITY.
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION CDT INTEND
TO INVOLVE THEIR INFORMATION
SECURITY STAFF IN THE ROAD MAP
PLANNING PROCESS AND
INCORPORATE A NUMBER OF PRIVACY
CONTROLS INTO A SINGLE DIGITAL
IDENTIFICATION PLATFORM. WELL
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THESE AND
OTHER PRIVACY AND SECURITY
MEASURES ARE CONTAINED IN THE
STATE ONE BUSINESS ANALYSIS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD BENEFIT FROM
A MORE DELIBERATIVE AND FEDERAL
PLANNING PROCESS FOR DIGITAL
IDENTIFICATION. THAT ADDRESSES
NOT DISPLAYED EVENT STAKEHOLDER
CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE RISKS AND SCOPE OF THE
PROJECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND WEBER FINANCE I NEED TO
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL AND
IT'S NOTHING THAT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU I'M SORRY YOU BROKE
UP THERE FOR A FOR A BIT CAN
YOU REPEAT THAT. BLACK ONE OF
THE FINEST. FINANCES OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU FOR THAT ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. OKAY
I HAVE A COUPLE OF WHAT POLICY
PROBLEM IS A PROPOSAL
ATTEMPTING TO RESOLVE. BECAUSE
THE- MANAGEMENT USER
IDENTIFICATION IS DISPERSED
ACROSS ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT SYSTEMS THAT THAT
USER EXPERIENCE IS VERY
DISJOINTED AND FOR THE
RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA WORKING
WITH STATE GOVERNMENT IT DOES
NOT GIVE A CONSOLIDATED FEEL
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE THE- IS THAT
DISBURSEMENT OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION. BY BEING ABLE TO
CENTRALIZE THAT WE BELIEVE WE
CAN NOT ONLY DO THE MUCH BETTER
AS A STATE ORGANIZATION BUT WE
CAN MAINTAIN ITS CURRENT WITH
PRIVACY LAWS WITH ANY BEST
PRACTICES AND WITH INDUSTRY
PRACTICES AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
TO A PROVIDES A MUCH SAFER A
DIGITAL. ENVIRONMENT RESIDENTS
CALIFORNIA. WHAT CALIFORNIANS
THAT RECEIVE ANY BASIC SERVICE
SUCH AS SENDING THEIR CHILDREN
TO SCHOOL ARE GETTING HELP WITH
HEALTHCARE OR APPLYING FOR A
DRIVER'S LICENSE. ESSENTIALLY
ALSO BE REQUIRED TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY TO
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES. NO WE'RE
NOT THIS IS AN OPTIMAL SOLUTION
SO THE RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA
WHEN THEY SIGN UP FOR A WEBSITE
WILL IDENTIFY THE SITES THAT
THEY WANT THAT INFORMATION SURE
TO. SO IF THEY SIGN UP-
ESSENTIALLY IN THIS IDENTITY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WE CAN PROVE
THE IDENTITY OF A HEALTHY
PERSON FOR GRASP FOR EXAMPLE.
BY THEY CAN SAY THAT THEY ONLY
WANT TAX HE SHARED WITH
SPECIFIC DEPARTMENTS AND CAN
CONCERT WE WILL NOW. WORK MORE
INFORMATION WE WILL NOT. BE
SURE NOW WITH A LITTLE. WITHOUT
CONSENT IT'S ALSO AN OPT OUT
PROGRAM WHICH STATE ARE
SUBSEQUENTLY CHANGED HER MIND
AND WOULD LIKE TO WITHDRAW THEY
CAN DO THAT ON DEMAND. WHEN
THEY CHOOSE TO DO THAT. WHAT
THANK YOU WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY PROVIDE THE ID
INFORMATION TO FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS IF
REQUESTED. WE'LL FOLLOW THE
DIRECTION OF STATE OR FEDERAL
LAW AND ANY EXECUTIVE ORDERS
WILL OR OTHER ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU I KNOW ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT. WE ARE HOLDING THIS ITEM
OPEN FOR THE MOMENT AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR NINE ISSUES THAT
WE ARE HEARING WE ARE GOING TO
GO BACK TO. THE ISSUES THAT WE
NEED MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO
VOTING JUST ONE MOMENT AND GO
BACK TO THAT. THANK YOU TO THE
PANEL FOR PARTICIPATING THANK
YOU. NOW CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG WE ARE AN ISSUE TO. IF
YOU ONE ONE TO OFFICE ON EVERY
OFF WHAT ITEMS ARE YES OF- WAS
ISSUES. ONE THREE TWO TWENTY
TWO. AT THE REQUEST OF IT'S OUT
OF. TO ME READ OFF THE MOST HE
VOTE ON IT WITH OKAY. MOTION
ONE IS VOTE ON WHEN I. CAN THIS
pYES SIR NOT ONLY ISSUES WERE
THROUGH 222-333-5250 FIFTY FIVE
FIFTY A AND SIXTY. THAT'S RIGHT
THANK. SECOND MOTION AND IS
VOTE ON ISSUE TWENTY THIRTY
FOUR FIFTY AND. FOR NINE. THIS
AREA. HI. OKAY AND THEN TO THE
ITEMS THAT WERE HEARD. IF YOU
TO- BOB ONE LACKEY HI. IF YOU
THREE BLACKIE I. ISSUE FOUR
LACKEY I. ISSUE FIVE FLAK. I.
THE ISSUE NUMBER SIX WACKY. HI
AND I NEED TO VOTE CHANGE-
ISSUE SEVEN WILL CHANGE FROM I
DO OF STAYING. TAKE A PHOTO OF
IT. ISSUE SEVEN FOR A SPECIAL
ELECTION. WE WERE. THAT WAS
HOLD OPEN ISSUE. EIGHT ISSUE
EIGHT VOTE CHANGE I DO I'M
STAYING. OKAY. AND CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG ALL THOSE MEASURES
ARE YES- MEASURES ALL MEASURES
ARE OUT LET'S GO NOW TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WHICH IS TO SPEAK THEY
MAY RAISE OUR HANDS AND I WILL
ASK THEM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I WOULD ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC RESPECT FOR THE GOAL
DISTANCING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
THINGS UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING. LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME IF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE YOU MAY
CONNECT AT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. USING THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN- OPERATOR LET'S
BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT PRESS THE
ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN AS A
REMINDER TO COMMENT PRESS THE
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE NEED
TO HAVE ABOUT SIX IN THE QUEUE
LOCAL TIME FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS RYAN
JOY CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE THE SUPPORT
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE I'VE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT. OUR
COMPANY HAS MADE SUBSTANTIAL
PROGRESS ON HOUSING COSTS IN
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS IN THIS
PROPOSAL IS KEY TO THE SUCCESS
OF THE POLICIES AFFECTING MANY
FORMER ASSEMBLY BILLS RELATING
TO EIGHTY USING A HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. ARE
CRITICALLY WE WILL ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE WILL PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL GOERNMENTS
SAID THEY CAN SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT THE LOG. AND IN IT IN
THE RARE CASE WHEN A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL FULLY DECIDES
TO BOB BYERLEY THE LAW AND IF
YOU CAN AFFORD IT. CALIFORNIA
BE STRONG SUPPORT THIS.
PROPOSAL AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT.
MAX SILVA CAROLINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GLAD. I AM THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'VE BEEN
BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS STILL
IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHT CD ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PRESSURE HE REFERRED TO
A NEW HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
UNIT TO MONITOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THERE WAS NO
MENTION OF ASSISTANCE. THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT HAS
NOW BEEN REBRANDED TO HOUSING
ASSISTANCE LAW IN THE RUN UP TO
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
KENNETT GOVERNOR QUOTED
MCKINSEY AND COMPANY OF THE
STATE'S HOUSING NEEDS IN TWENTY
TWENTY LEAGUE GOVERNOR WALKED
BACK THE KINSEY AND COMPANY
NUMBER CALLING IT ASPIRATIONAL
AND A STRETCH GOAL. NOW IN THE
RUN UP TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE
GOVERNOR HAS MADE THE HA YOU
PROPOSAL. THE CASF STANDSTILL
URGES USING FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION TO ACTUALLY BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NOT CREATE
YET. ANOTHER LAYER OF
BUREAUCRACY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. MACULATA LINE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS THAT BOWLING
REPRESENTING INDIA ACTION IN
ALAMEDA FOR EVERYONE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER FIGHTING
IN THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
UNIT I WANTED TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE IN
AT CALIFORNIAN B. THE CALIBER
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
WILL. NOT CREATE ANY NEW
RESPONSIBILITY IT'S VERY CITY
BUT JUST ALLOW THEM TO DO THE
JOB THAT THEY WERE SET UP TO DO.
AND WE SUPPORT THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. AXOLOTL
LINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE TEN SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS JEFF NEAL AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- WE APPRECIATE THE
HEARING TODAY AND YOU HEAR IN
THE RECALL REIMBURSEMENT- ITEM
I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT
ACTUALLY MADAM TURN YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT- HOW MUCH D.
REIMBURSEMENT SHOULD BE OR THE
OR THE STATE FUNDING QUESTION
SHOULD BE- YOU KNOW GIVEN. HOW
MUCH MORE THAN THE STATE
ALREADY- PAYS INTO THAT TODAY
CONDUCT OF ELECTIONS AND THAT'S
AN INTERESTING QUESTION AND
THAT I THINK MS GREEN-
PARTIALLY ANSWERED- UNDER. BUT
THE MOST RECENT ELECTION OF
COURSE THE STATE PROVIDED
SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
FUND THAT YOU KNOW THE
EXTRAORDINARY NEED PANDEMIC
COSTS IN THE POLICY CHANGES.
THAT WERE PUT INTO EFFECT AT
THE STATE IS ALSO GIVEN TO BE
MONEY FOR EQUIPMENT- NEW VOTING
EQUIPMENT IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS- BUT ASIDE FROM THAT THE
STATE ACTUALLY DOESN'T
PARTICIPATE. IN THAT DID THAT
COST FOR THAT CONDUCT AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATION OF ELECTIONS AND
SO- YOU KNOW GET IN MOST
ELECTIONS. V. AT CITIES THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ALL. REIMBURSED THEIR
SHARE OF THE ELECTION COSTS BUT
FOR RECALL CAMPAIGN OF COURSE
THAT WON'T BE HAPPENING. AND SO
THE ENTIRE COST OF THE ELECTION
WILL BE BORNE BY COUNTIES
THAT'S WHAT WE THINK IT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE FOR THE STATE TO
PROVIDE. WE HOPE IT A
SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF THE
FUNDING FOR THAT LECTURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AXOLOTL
LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI I AM ADAM BOOKBINDER PINK
CITY OF CAMPBELL PURPOSING
STOPPING HIM BE THANKING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THIS QUARTER
ISSUE FIVE HEALTHY KIND OF
BUILDING UNIT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. MAXIMAL THE
LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY AND AROUND
US I'M FROM THE CITY OF
MOUNTAIN VIEW AND I'M
REPRESENTING NOT CAN YOU GIVE
ME IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE FIVE THE
HOUSING ACOUNTABILITY UNIT AT
ALL LIKE THAT HELPING. TO
GATHER. THANK THANK YOU FOR
THAT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MACBOOK PRO LINE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL I HAD. YES- ROB
NELSON CALLING FROM OUR HOTEL
ON BEHALF OF THE IN THE
ACTUALLY ACTION AND ANOTHER FOR
EVERYONE I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT ITEM NUMBER FIVE
HOUSING ACCOUNT COUNTY.
BUILDING UNIT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. MEXICO
TIMELINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE WELL
I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS- JORDAN CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS JUST WANT TO SHARE
OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE- THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE STATE HAS
WORKED REALLY HARD OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS- TO CREATE
LAWS TO ADDRESS OUR EVER
WORSENING HOUSING CRISIS BUT
IT'S AN UNFORTUNATE REALITY
THAT SOME CITIES ARE UNWILLING
TO FAULT THEM. THEY HAVE TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE- THAT HA YOU
FELT THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS ISSUE
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. MAX SILVA TO LINE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE CALL HAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEAN HER CALLING IN
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA I IN ALLIANCE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- EIGHT AND SEVEN THAT
COST TO BE. SPECIAL ELECTION.
WE OF COURSE HE SAID THAT
CONVERSATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO ADDITIONAL DIALOGUE ABOUT
OPERATING SOME RESOURCES TO
CHINESE FOR ADMINISTERING THAT
ELECTION WHICH- I THINK ALL
SIGNS POINT TO WHAT COULD BE A
POTENTIALLY COSTLY LINED UP
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION AND I CAN
APPRECIATE- YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. NEXT PHOTO LINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE FIVE OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT AND I'M
DISASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT MADE BY THE
PREVIOUS SUPPORTERS THANK YOU.
AND NOTHING TO ALMOST TO LINE
SEVENTY FOUR. BY MIGHT HAVE
REGARDING YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS RYAN OLSON I AM
FROM- CULVER CITY CALIFORNIA
AND A MEMBER OF CULVER CITY FOR
MORE HOMES AND CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE FIVE THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK
YOU NEXT COLOR. METSOVO
TIMELINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A BURNING
L. I'M CALLING WITH THE
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA MD- IN SAN
FRANCISCO I'M ALSO AS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE NUMBER FIVE TO
HOUSING CALEDONIAN- OUT THE
WORK AND URBAN PLANNING FIRM
THAT DOES A LOT OF HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT IMPLEMENTATION
PIECE FOR MEASURING AND
EVALUATING- THAT MEANT A LOT
BUT OUR STATE HAS IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE DROPPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I THINK.
IMPORTANT. I THINK HE'S AND I
HOPE YOU SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. MAX OVER
TO LINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ARE
COMMON I AM NINE SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA JUST NOT SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MY PLANNING
COMMISSION- AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF A GROUP CALLED URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS WHICH- OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL CRISIS. BY WAYNE
SELDEN CONSEQUENCES. YOU KNOW
OF OUR COMMUTER WHILE BY AND
FAMILY ALL THE PEOPLE THAT NEED
TO WORK HERE- I AM ALSO
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
REVIVED THE HOUSING BILLS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR.
BACK BELOW TREELINE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
EVERYONE MY NAME IS ALFRED Q. I
LIVE IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
NUMBER OF EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE
AND OFF OF CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE FIVE THAT HAVING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NICE COLOR. BACK TO A
MOTEL LINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS REBECCA
BROWN I'M CALLING FROM THE
VALLEY IN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
INTERCOUNTY DMB IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. MAXIMAL
TIELINE AT PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS OF
MY NAME IS PROPER FOLLOW TOLD
I'M WITH SANTA CRUZ THE A B.
AND I'M ALSO CALLING IT IN
SUPPORT OF THE MUCH NEEDED.
FUNDING FOR ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. BACKSTROM OF CAROLINE
AB TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS SEVEN ZERO THREE I
AM A MEMBER OF SANTA CRUZ CAN
BE I LIVE IN SCOTTS VALLEY
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE FIVE THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
BACKSTROM OF THAILAND EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS TOBY MARCHAND ON
CALLING WITH WEBSITE FOR
EVERYONE FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
FIVE THE HOUSING AREA. THANK
YOU MUCH APPRECIATE A CALL FROM
LOS ANGELES NEXT CALLER. MAXIMO
TIMELINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
CALL I HAD. THIS IS KELLY
CALLING FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL CALLING IN UPPORT OF
THIS YEAR THANK HOUSING COUNTY
THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT CALLER.
MAX OVER TIME EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL I HAD. HOLLY FOR
MANY DECADES THE BLACK HAWK
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING AT THE
PORT OF ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA TMG PARTNER DANIELLE
PROPERTIES FOR AND THE COUNCIL
AND UNTIL DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. AT THIS
TIME WE SHOW NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU OPERATOR THAT.
AND I BELIEVE THATWILL
CONCLUDE AT THIS HEARING ON
THIS BEAUTIFUL MAY THE FOURTH
BE WITH YOU ON SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
BUDGET I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
A PRIVILEGE AND- THANK OUR
PREVIOUS BUDGET SO FOR
CONSULTANT JENNIFER DUONG WHO'S
NOW. INTEGRATES RESPONSIBILITY
IN BEING CHIEF OF STAFF TO OUR
OUR BUDGET CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TNG AND WELCOME TO
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR MICHAELIS AND
WHO'S THE JOINING US AS FORMER
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGGIE JONES
SAWYER SO WE WELCOME YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOU- ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING FOR COMMITTEE
SO WELCOME AND THANK YOU AND OF
COURSE THANK YOU TO OUR
WONDERFUL STAFFED AND EVEN AND
CHRISTIAN ARE CHIEF CONSULTANT-
FOR BUDGET. AND THAT CONCLUDES
TODAY'S HEARING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.